mes chers collègues nous concluons nos
travaux de la journée et je souhaite au
nom de l'ensemble des membres de la
commission d'enquête la bienvenue à
Madame Tondelier secrétaire national
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts je salue
également nos collègues parlementaires
qui l'accompagnent Monsieur Daniel
salmon sénateur d'Ille-et-Vilaine et
Claude Ruffat
député européen bienvenue également aux
autres membres de la délégation un
à pardonnez-moi pardonnez-moi en effet
oui monsieur gourmand et Monsieur Vito
donc soyez les bienvenus
un questionnaire vous a préalablement
été transmis par notre rapporteur
Florent Boudier
nous n'aurons sans doute pas le loisir
d'aborder l'intégralité de ces questions
du moins lors de l'audition donc si vous
pouviez dans un second temps nous nous
transmettre les éléments écrits ça nous
sera très utile comme vous le savez nous
enquêtons sur les violences qui ont
émaillées les manifestations dans notre
pays au cours du printemps dernier du
point de vue des manifestants comme de
celui des forces de l'ordre
ce programme comporte en quelque sorte
de théâtre distinct il y a d'une part
les manifestations liées à la réforme
des retraites qui ont donné lieu à des
exactions essentiellement urbaines et il
y a d'autre part un certain nombre de
rassemblements qu'on veut créer autour
de mot d'ordre
de type environnemental avec des espaces
qui eux sont principalement ruraux nous
pourrons évoquer les deux sujets mais au
vu des fonctions qui sont les vôtres
dans le parti qui est également le vôtre
c'est principalement le second aspect
qui a justifié votre invitation devant
notre commission d'enquête vous avez
d'ailleurs Twitter hier que vous seriez
entendu à votre demande je me réjouis de
cette convergence spontanée de nos
objectifs entre la commission d'enquête
et les vôtres mes premières questions
qui ont vocation introduire le débat
seront très simple
madame la secrétaire nationale en
premier lieu en tant que partie
écologiste qui porte les objectifs de
protection de l'environnement qui sont
inscrits dans vos statuts
quels sont les voix de revendication que
vous considérez
quelque sorte hors du champ démocratique
nous étions hier à Sainte Soline nous
avons vu des armes blanches des armes
incendiaires des armes de j'ai saisi par
les gendarmes nous avons écouté un
certain nombre de récits de destruction
de biens d'un certain nombre
d'agriculteurs nous avons observé le
terrain qui exclut assez évidemment que
des manifestants et plus ignorer la
survenue d'affrontement violent avec les
forces de l'ordre puisque le terrain se
prête quand même à ce que on puisse se
rendre compte que si on ne souhaite pas
de contact physique et bien il y aura
pas de contact physique ce qui ne veut
évidemment pas dire que tous les
manifestants étaient présents dans un
esprit de violence d'ailleurs quand on
échange avec les forces de l'ordre leur
typologie consiste à dire sur les 8000
personnes présentes
2000 d'entre elles étaient
violentes où on manifesté de la violence
et
6000 ne l'ont pas fait nous avons noté
enfin
le dédain
ostensible des organisateurs à
l'encontre des interdictions
préfectorales d'une part et des
décisions juridictionnelles les
confirmant et vous-même avez selon la
presse pris part à cette manifestation
interdite en sachant qu'il s'agissait
d'une infraction contraventionnelle bref
quelle est la limite de l'action
politique est-ce la loi la violence
éventuellement la violence contre les
personnes parce que encore une fois hier
ce qui a été très très intéressant en
allant sur place c'était aussi de de
noter que comment dire il y avait bien
avant la manifestation un certain nombre
de messages qui avaient été envoyés sur
les réseaux et qui indiquait clairement
que le risque en tout cas
de dérive violentes étaient
assez manifeste d'autant plus que
comment dire certains avaient
semble-t-il envoyé des messages très
clairs consistant à dire que l'objectif
était non pas
non pas de simplement revendiquer mais
dans des coudes très précisément avec
les forces de l'ordre et en second lieu
les prises de distance avec la légalité
vous vous sentez également
préjudiciables puisque vous avez fait
l'objet au cours de vos déplacements et
on l'a vu de menaces et de pression qui
ont opéré votre propre liberté de
mouvement et votre liberté d'expression
or elle est évidemment
également je pense importante pour vous
donc comment rétablir la primauté de la
règle de droit solution à laquelle tous
les républicains devraient se ranger
pour trancher les différences
d'appréciations sans risquer
recours à la violence nous nous sommes
finalement tous les perdants quand c'est
la violence qui prend le dessus c'est
l'état de droit qui recule donc si vous
voulez bien je vais procéder j'allais
dire à l'usage c'est-à-dire la
prestation de serment donc Madame et
Monsieur avant de vous donner la parole
et en application de l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance numéro
58-1100 du 17 novembre 1958 relatives
aux fonctionnements de nos assemblées
parlementaires je vais vous demander de
prêter serment de dire la vérité toute
la vérité et rien que la vérité comme
j'ai cru comprendre que vous aviez tous
vocation à vous exprimer je vais vous
inviter successivement si vous en êtes
d'accord madame et Messieurs de donc
vous avez branché le micro il faudra
l'éteindre pour que monsieur Ogier
puisse lui à son tour s'exprimer donc si
vous voulez simplement lever la main
droite et dire je le jure
alors je jure de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité et j'ajoute
par contre que Monsieur og il y a une
erreur il s'exprime pas il est venu
accompagner la délégation très bien
parfait dans ce dans ce cas-là
nous lui demanderons pas de prêter
serment monsieur salmon je vous en prie
je vous jure de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité toute la vérité je
vous en remercie Monsieur Vito
rien que la vérité et que la vérité ou
toute la nuit
merci
beaucoup ce corps man
attendez il faut que Monsieur oui il
faut voilà je vous en remercie et là il
faut voilà
merci infiniment donc sans être plus
long
madame la secrétaire nationale je vous
passe la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés je vous remercie de nous
accueillir aujourd'hui pour être donc
entendu dans un cadre d'écoute et
d'échanges je le sais républicain et je
le souhaite serein par votre commission
d'enquête
nous vous avons écrit au début de l'été
pour vous demander à être auditionné
parce que le sujet de votre commission
d'enquête contient particulièrement à
coeur nous avons chez les écologistes un
attachement sincère historique et
constant à la non-violence qui fait
partie de nos fondamentaux chez Europe
Écologie Les Verts notamment nous avons
toujours défendu l'idée que ce qui vient
avec la violence n'aboutit à rien de
positif jamais la non-violence est au
cœur de nos valeurs et de nos modes
d'action y compris la non-violence
verbale dans nos échanges entre nous et
avec les autres la réciproque n'est pas
toujours vrai nous regrettons et
condamnons donc toujours les violences
et nous l'avons notamment fait lors des
événements qui sont couverts par votre
commission d'enquête mais pas seulement
et cette précision nous tient à cœur
nous avons une position très ferme et
constante j'insiste sur ce mot constante
sur le sujet
nous espérons donc que le travail que
vous menez permettra d'éclairer la
représentation nationale et les Français
une commission d'enquête nous semble
être un outil adapté pour poser les
faits pour les objectifs pour avoir
l'espace et le temps loin du tumulte
imposé par l'information en continu de
prendre le recul nécessaire à la
manifestation de la vérité et au débat
indispensable pour comprendre ce qui
s'est joué dans ces manifestations cela
étant dit je me permettrai de vous faire
une petite remarque préalable je m'en
voudrais de ne pas la formuler et
j'espère que vous n'en prendrez pas
ombrage nous avons lu avec attention au
moment de son dépôt le 4 avril dernier
le texte de la demande de commission
d'enquête sur je cite la structuration
le financement l'organisation des
groupes muscules et la conduite des
manifestations illicites violentes nous
avons également pris connaissance du
rapport que la commission des lois a
travaillé pour l'autoriser
deux inquiétudes nous sont venus à
l'esprit chez les écologistes et nous
tenions à vous en faire par à la lecture
du titre même déjà de la Commission et
puis aussi de l'aspect non trace
partisan des signataires ou encore des
objectifs affichés par la résolution on
sent bien que la volonté n'est pas
nécessairement de comprendre les
dynamiques qui ont conduit à cette liste
événements et j'espère sincèrement que
votre travail permettra de dépasser
l'impression que peut laisser cette
résolution d'une commission d'enquête
finalement très politique qui
chercherait à utiliser ce bel outil de
notre vie parlementaire pour faire
avancer un agenda partisan au détriment
de la manifestation de la vérité
notre seconde inquiétude concerne le
champ des violences traité par votre
commission durant la période du 16 mars
au 3 mai 2023 de nombreuses violences
ont été commises contre des militants
écologistes vous n'avez parlé un peu en
introduction en liant d'ailleurs les
faits par exemple le 27 mars une
manifestation non autorisée elles n'ont
plus à aboutit à l'effraction par les
dizaines de personnes du domicile de la
présidente de scie chez par France deux
jours avant deux militants de la même
association avait été passée à tabac la
presse n'en a peu voire pas parlé ce ne
sont pas les seuls exemples j'en tiens
toute une série à votre disposition
pourra en parler et les violences envers
les écologistes attisés au plus haut de
l'État nous y reviendrons aussi si vous
le souhaitez sont réels et en
recrudescence à tel point que nous
travaillons avec de nombreuses
associations à créer un observatoire des
violences faites aux écologistes pour
mieux les objectifs et accompagner leur
victime encore il y a trois semaines le
maire d'une commune en Corrèze a défilé
sur un char qui déployait une banderole
sur laquelle était écrit mort aux écol
amer élu de la République appelant à la
haine envers les écologistes qui s'en
était mu dans la majorité dans le
gouvernement personne c'est aussi cela
le continuum de violence en France et en
tant que secrétaire national d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts qui condamne donc
toutes les violences je tiens à saisir
cette occasion pour alerter les
parlementaires présents parce que si
vous êtes présent c'est que vous êtes à
priori sensible à la question des
violences vu l'objet de la commission
d'enquête que le sujet des violences à
l'encontre des militants écologistes
mérite à mon avis aussi votre attention
et donc j'espère qu'on en parlera au
cours de cette audition ces préalable
étant posé je vais vous présenter notre
délégation du jour donc elle est
composée de trois députés européens vous
l'avez dit David Corman Benoît Biteau et
Claude grufin et d'un sénateur Daniel
salmon notre point commun il est très
simple nous avons vécu ensemble cette
terrible journée du 25 mars à
Sainte-Soline et nous sommes venus
solidement répondre à vos questions
parce que c'est comme ça que nous
fonctionnement chez Europe Écologie Les
Verts solidairement
nous répondrons à toutes vos questions
que toutes celles que vous aurez sur
tout ce que nous avons vu ce jour-là sur
ce que nous avons dit avant fait pendant
analyser depuis en toute sincérité en
toute transparence et avec soulagement
même je dirais parce qu'il est important
pour nous de concourir à l'établissement
de la vérité sur cette séquence on a
beaucoup parlé de vérité dans votre
introduction et dans la prestation de
serment notez par ailleurs que nous
étions aussi à toutes les manifestations
retraite et donc on pourra aussi vous
répondre sur le sujet
je vous ai écrit monsieur le rapporteur
pour vous demander à ce que nous soyons
auditionnés par votre commission parce
que c'est bien le rôle d'un parti
politique que nous représentons ici
aujourd'hui de témoigner ce qui s'est
joué à Sainte Soline la nature des
violences leur traitement médiatique la
bataille de la communication qui s'est
politiquement jouer en Suisse la posture
prise par le ministre de l'Intérieur et
les diverses récupérations politiques
qui s'en sont suivies sont un fait
politique majeur qui méritent
l'attention de l'assemblée nationale et
celle des Français vous le verrez dans
le témoignage il reste encore beaucoup
d'émotions
inutile de faire semblant que ça n'est
pas le cas c'est impossible
ces quelques heures d'une violence
intense ont laissé des traces chez tous
les participants et beaucoup y compris
nous avons vécu un sérieux traumatisme
ce qui a nécessité l'organisation y
compris par notre mouvement à
destination nos adhérents présents de
séquences de débriefing psychologique
assez édifiantes là aussi on pourra y
revenir si vous le souhaitez parmi les
30 000 manifestants présents ce jour-là
dont l'immense majorité sont des
pacifistes convaincus et pratiquants
quelques-uns garderont des séquelles la
vie tous les cinq et les autres
parlementaires présents ce jour-là avons
essuyé dans les semaines suivantes un
flot de critique non pas parce que nous
aurions commis des violences chacun sait
ici que ce n'est pas le cas mais pour le
simple fait que nous ayons été sur place
c'est donc pour nous aussi le moment
d'expliquer pourquoi nous étions sur
place
évidemment la première raison notre
présence à Sainte-Soline vous la
connaissez ce sont les méga bassines et
leur absurdité économique et écologique
pomper de l'eau dans les nappes
phréatiques qui sont désormais rarement
pleines 72% des nappes phréatiques alors
où je vous parle sont en dessous de leur
niveau normal pour les mettre à l'air
libre là où elle s'évapore c'est une
idée qui en dit long sur notre capacité
à développer des solutions insensées
pour faire perdurer un modèle agricole à
bout de souffle tous les scientifiques
le disent le meilleur réservoir d'eau
possible a été conçu par la nature il
s'appelle la nappe phréatique
Benoît Biteau qui est ici aujourd'hui
qui en plus d'être parlementaire
européen et aussi exploitant agricole en
Charente et devenu un expert de ce sujet
on pourra vous en parler des heures mais
telle n'est pas le chant de cette
commission nous étions d'ailleurs tous
les deux présents à la précédente
manifestation de Sainte-Souline en
octobre 2022 et lui donc qui est un
voisin de ses projets il y en a
d'ailleurs pas raté une depuis le début
du dossier il y a des années
nous souhaitons donc venir ce 28 mars
pour mettre en lumière cette lutte
contre l'absurde contre l'accaparement
par quelques-uns d'une ressource commune
et à partir du moment à la manifestation
a été interdite nous avons évidemment
pris le temps d'échanger avec nos
collègues les choses ont été très
simples très claires et très rapide il y
avait à peu près 200 manifestants
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts des
militants d'Europe écologie des Verts
qui nous avaient annoncé cette
organisation
vous voyez faut prévoir le logement le
covoiturage etc donc ça s'organise à
l'avance et qui nous confirmait
maintenir leur participation 200
militants d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
compte tenu des risques qui étaient
annoncés c'est bien ma place d'être à
leur côté c'est ça aussi être chef de
partie et les parlementaires ici
présents ont eu le même raisonnement et
les mêmes inquiétudes sur ce qu'il se
passerait sur place sur les risques qui
seraient encourus par les manifestants
nous sommes dit que nous serions plus
utiles à Sainte Soline que chez nous
devant notre télé
et évidemment ça s'est confirmé le jour
J nous sommes retrouvés à assister des
blessés graves en urgence vitale pour
l'une d'entre elles une jeune fille
âgée d'à peine 19 ans qui a pleuré
pendant des heures victimes d'un tir
tendu de grenades en pleine tête puis
d'autres grenades une fois au sol
regroupés avec d'autres blessés que nous
avons tenté de protéger en formant une
chaîne humaine des tirs de Grenade
lacrymogènes la fiction et la blessant à
nouveau aux membres inférieurs cela
restera une expérience qui marque à vie
douloureuse intimement et politiquement
nous avons remué ciel et terre pendant
des heures appelez les services de la
première ministre qui nous ont répondu
échanger avec la préfète qui nous a
répondu avec les services de secours qui
nous ont répondu aussi nous pouvions
voir à quelques dizaines de mètres des
ambulances mais pour des raisons vous
éclaircirez peut-être il a fallu
attendre des heures pour que les blessés
les plus graves soient pris en charge
nous n'oublierons jamais jamais la peur
la souffrance les pleurs l'impuissance
et nous demandons que la lumière soit
faite sur cela également vu le nom de
force de l'ordre annoncé il est
incompréhensible que les secours que les
secours n'est pas été organisés en
conséquence c'est une faute lourde
pas la seule mais c'est une faute lourde
en tant que chef d'un parti politique ce
que je souhaite avant tout et je
terminerai là-dessus c'est que face à
des événements aussi graves que ceux qui
se sont déroulés qui ont conduit à
plusieurs dizaines de gendarmes blessés
certains gravement auxquels nous pensons
également évidemment évidemment mais
aussi plusieurs de centaines de
manifestants blessés dont certains ont
été entre la vie et la mort pendant
plusieurs semaines nous puissions faire
l'effort de l'objectivité et de sortir
des querelles partisanes j'aimerais
qu'un message soit retenu aujourd'hui en
tant que partie politique nous sommes
une force de médiation entre un
mouvement social qui porte une colère
légitime que nous comprenons peut-être
forcément mieux que beaucoup puisque
nous en sommes proches et les
institutions toutes les institutions qui
sont malheureusement encore trop
inactives face aux immenses défis
environnementaux qui se révèlent à nos
jours après jour je rappelle que la
justice européenne et la justice
française condamnent d'ailleurs
certaines de ces institutions pour une
action climatique pour manquement sur la
qualité de l'air pour non respect des
règles européennes sur la chasse pour
manque de politique sur la biodiversité
encore cet été donc c'est pas une vue de
l'esprit
c'est dans cet état d'esprit en tout cas
que j'ai rencontré la première ministre
peu après sainte Soline et j'ai
bénéficié je dois dire d'une grande
écoute c'est aussi dans cet état
d'esprit que j'ai remis le sujet sur la
table 30 août dernier lors des fameuses
12 heures des réunions entre Emmanuel
Macron et les chefs de partir à
Saint-Denis et je continuerai de le
faire nous pensons que le gouvernement
fait une erreur de jugement
significative en refusant de s'appuyer
sur les corps intermédiaires pour mieux
comprendre les attentes de la société et
mener une action qui soit davantage
partagée par nos concitoyens les partis
politiques tous les syndicats tous les
militants du climat les associations ne
sont pas des forces de blocage mais des
relais puissants les criminalisés comme
on l'a encore vu hier avec la garde à
vue d'un patron d'une des plus grandes
fédérations de la CGT est inquiétant
lorsque cela renie l'importance des
syndicats par exemple pour mener le
dialogue inclusif indispensable à une
transformation positive de notre société
beaucoup de droits que nous avons
aujourd'hui nous leur devons
d'une manière plus globale nous sommes
très inquiets de voir que certains
tombent dans la tentation de ne pas
dialoguer avec les opposants mais de les
criminaliser qualifier les militants
écologistes d'écotéroristes comme la
féministe de l'Intérieur pourtant garant
de nos libertés publiques et de la
cohésion des institutions c'est la
définition de son ministère ceux sans
aucun fondement juridique ne fera pas
disparaître le problème que pose le défi
écologique cela par ailleurs nous met en
danger ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
tenter de dissoudre les soulèvements de
la terre sans fondement juridique
sérieux ne fera jamais disparaître le
problème que c'est soulèvements portent
la décision du Conseil d'État de cet été
suite à notre référé même si elle est
dans l'attente d'un jugement au fond
montre d'ailleurs il suffit de lire le
communiqué de presse assez édifiant du
Conseil d'État et tous les juristes ont
compris que les atteintes aux libertés
associatives prennent elles aussi une
tournure inquiétante dans notre pays le
mouvement associatif fait des
fédérations qui représentent toutes ces
associations l'expliquerait mieux que
moi mais nous pouvons également échanger
sur le sujet parce que nous sommes
plusieurs ici à beaucoup le travail les
partis politiques les syndicats les
associations ont une la responsabilité
de capter les mouvements de la société
pour les inscrire dans le champ
démocratique il faut reconnaître cette
fonction et donc la protéger au risque
sinon d'un affaiblissement démocratique
d'un affaissement d'ailleurs
démocratique aussi que nous nous
redoutons tous pour le dire autrement en
démocratie on dit alors ce qu'on va
faire aujourd'hui ensemble on convainc
ça on verra on construit des accords on
acte des désaccords mais on ne
criminalise pas ses opposants nous
devons française et aux Français de ne
pas récupérer ces violences pour faire
avancer un agenda politicien mais bien
de prendre le recul nécessaire à
l'établissement de la vérité et éclairer
les mécanismes qui ont abouti à ces
événements avec nos collègues nous en
ferons notre part en vous livrant notre
témoignage aujourd'hui cette audition ne
suffira pas on sait bien mais nous
espérons qu'elle participera à élargir
et ouvrir ce débat que nous sommes
déterminés à mener jusqu'au bout je vous
remercie
je vous remercie je vais tout de suite
passer la parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur et nous pourrons à ce moment
là rentrer dans les questions réponses
et j'invite les collègues qui souhaitent
poser des questions de se manifester
auprès de moi donc monsieur le
rapporteur je vous passe tout de suite
la parole merci monsieur le Président
merci madame la secrétaire nationale
votre volonté de venir devant la
commission en effet rejoint de la nôtre
de vous associer à nos travaux et c'est
très bien comme ça et je dois quand même
saluer tout particulièrement le député
mytho parce que nous avons siéger sur
les mêmes bancs de l'hémicycle régional
donc à l'Aquitaine il se trouve que à
l'époque nous faisions partie même de la
même majorité régionale les choses ont
évolué depuis
je ne sais comment conclure d'ailleurs
mon propos
je voudrais
quelques précisions madame la secrétaire
nationale et merci d'ailleurs pour votre
état d'esprit sur la dénonciation
constante en effet de votre formation
pour l'éthique de la non-violence
l'intitulé de la commission d'enquête il
a évolué à ma demande le mot
organisation a disparu et il a disparu
parce que j'estimais Cassandra d'autres
collègues je l'ai déjà dit tout à
l'heure devant les organisations
syndicales que le mot terme
d'organisation était
charrier toute une série d'ambiguïtés
par exemple comme ce n'était pas
l'objectif visé à l'évidence j'ai
souhaité et j'ai proposé par amendement
qu'il soit supprimé quant au champ des
violences c'est un sujet en tant que tel
qu'appelle-t-on la non-violence
où s'arrête-elle est-ce que la
désobéissance civile est une violence
envers la loi
est-ce que c'est est-ce qu'elle est
tolérable est-ce qu'elle est acceptée
jusqu'où peut-elle un vrai sujet de
l'interrogation
je vais en venir à des questions très
précises madame associer internationale
parce qu'une commission d'enquête
consonnons l'indique vise à explorer en
profondeur un certain nombre de
situations dans le chant temporel qui
est le nôtre c'est-à-dire à compter du
16 mars dernier jusqu'au 3 mai 2023
lorsque nous nous sommes déplacés hier
à Sainte Soline il y a me semble-t-il
un premier constat j'allais dire
physique
géographique que nous pouvons établir
de façon me semble-t-il relativement
objectif
c'est que il n'y a pas d'affrontement
possible
avec les forces de l'ordre
il n'y a aucun affrontement possible
avec les forces de l'ordre s'il n'est
pas souhaité
souhaitée par des individus violents
je ne fais pas l'amalgame entre les 8000
personnes présentes dont 10% d'individus
violents à peu près selon les
estimations qui varient entre 800 et
2000 personnes selon les autorités je ne
sais pas la mais il n'y a pas
d'affrontement possible dans cette
situation précise à Sainte-Souline s'il
n'y a pas volonté
d'affrontement s'il n'y a pas
préméditation organisation de
l'affrontement je m'explique les forces
de l'ordre sont disposées autour d'une
infrastructure et nulle part ailleurs
elles sont statiques elles sont
statiques à l'inverse des manifestations
urbaines
autre sujet
elles sont statiques et par conséquent
dans un champ de visibilité dans un
champ tout court d'ailleurs un champ de
visibilité très fort il n'y a aucune
autre façon de s'affronter aux forces de
l'ordre que de le vouloir et de
parcourir plusieurs centaines de mères
de mètres dans l'intention d'aller au
contact dans l'intention de la fontement
d'ailleurs les images
vidéos indépendante ou officielle
regardons tout de même que la
cartographie présentait hier par les
forces de l'ordre mais surtout nos
propres constats encore une fois
géographique et physique nous laisse
plutôt penser ce que je viens de
formuler est-ce que c'est votre
interprétation
et est-ce que ce sont les constats que
vous avez pu faire sur place
premièrement deuxièmement nous avons
rencontré hier
les élus locaux
maire devant
souligne je tiens monsieur le Président
sous votre contrôle à les remercier à la
fois pour la sincérité de leurs propos
et le fait qu'ils ont vraiment pris le
temps de nous apporter des éléments
d'information le vendredi matin selon le
maire de bronzée
le vendredi matin à 7h30 un certain
nombre d'individus
parviennent dans sa commune pour
s'installer et l'ambiance est bonne
enfance dit-il et nous nous sommes prêts
à le croire et puis aux progressivement
au cours de la journée dans l'après-midi
en particulier n'est plus du tout le
même profil d'autres personnes se sont
se sont allégées des personnes qui sont
cagoulées qui d'ailleurs parfois court
dans le village vont sur un objectif
ciblé dont lui ignore totalement la
destination précise il se trouve que
selon les autorités je suis très prudent
ne soit pas à la place des forces de
l'ordre ou de la préfète par exemple des
Deux-Sèvres il s'agissait en particulier
d'aller bloquer
LGV Bordeaux Poitiers Paris
donc on voit que sur place des signes
avant-coureurs d'élevant Audi après-midi
que la géographie des lieux la stratégie
statique des forces de l'ordre ne sont
pas dispersées sur le champ il n'y a pas
des groupes qui seraient disposés de
façon à
créer un phénomène par exemple de Nas il
semble quand même qu'il soit très
difficile
de
passer à côté de ce phénomène donc c'est
mon deuxième point de vue puis troisième
point de vue vous dites la troisième
question pardon deuxième question
troisième question troisième sujet vous
dites risque annoncé
mais précisément nous contourner on
écoute les élus locaux les maires de
communes modestes
le risque ont couru il le voit dès le
vendredi après-midi
parce qu'il voit qu'il y a des individus
qui ne sont pas ceux que vous citez ils
sont surtout pas les 200 militants
écologistes pas du tout là on est sur
d'autres profils sont là pour autre
chose eux voient qu'il y a un risque
vous vous êtes responsable politique la
partie importante qui s'inscrit dans
notre histoire politique vous connaissez
ces risques
et vous en concluez c'est une question
pas de mise en cause et vous en concluez
qu'on peut y aller
on peut même y aller je parle sous le
contrôle de collègues députés présents
avec l'écharpe
mais c'est un débat et donc voilà moi
j'aimerais comprendre c'est à dire le
risque apparaît de plus en plus réel
nous avons appris aussi de la part de la
préfète des autorités générales de la
région sud-ouest par exemple on dit
qu'il y a une stratégie de communication
à mon d'alerte sur les risques éventuels
on peut être partagé sur l'opportunité
de cette façon de communiquer en tout
cas c'est ce que je pense
personnellement et voyez risque concouru
ils sont réels ils sont constatés ils
correspondent à des individus qui ne
sont pas les militants écologistes que
vous avez encadré et il y a malgré tout
pour vous une démarche qui consiste à y
aller il y a quelques instants le
secrétaire général de la CFTC était ici
il disait lorsque une manifestation est
spontanée
ou lorsque les interdite mon
organisation syndicale disait-il ne s'y
rend pas parce qu'elle considère que le
risque de violence est trop grand pour
être associé même indirectement d'une
certaine façon à ce moment voilà les
trois axes de questionnement que le
souhaitez aborder avec vous merci
monsieur le rapporteur madame tanji
avant de vous repasser tout de suite la
parole j'ajoute à cela que dans les
témoignages que nous avons recueillis
hier ce qui semble ressortir je dis bien
je mets aussi le conditionnel mais enfin
en tout cas témoignage que nous avons eu
aussi bien les mers que les
représentants de l'État ont rencontré de
très importantes difficultés à établir
une relation avec des organisateurs et
donc c'est un point qui qui est revenu
j'allais dire quasiment on continue
durant durant la journée rendant là
aussi enfin mettant en perspective le
fait que par rapport à ce qui se fait
habituellement quand des manifestations
sont organisées et bien il y a tout un
dispositif qui permet d'assurer
d'ailleurs la sécurité des manifestants
eux-mêmes puisque je le rappelle une
nouvelle fois le principe même dans
notre Constitution c'est que la
manifestation et le droit de manifester
est une est un droit de nature
constitutionnelle et donc là on se
retrouve dans une situation où la
difficulté qui nous a été en tout cas
qui a été fortement développé hier c'est
de dire que les conditions d'une
manifestation sur elle ne semblait
absolument pas réunie et donc ce qui
nous intéresse ici en tant que
commission d'enquête c'est de savoir
quels sont les éléments qui dans votre
prise de décision encore une fois comme
le disait sur le rapporteur sommes pas
là pour porter un jugement de valeur pas
du tout ça on est dans une optique très
très trans partisane dans une commission
d'enquête qu'est-ce qui vous permet de
dire que et bien voilà il
y avait des éléments qui qui
permettaient en fait une présence sur
sur place y compris d'un certain nombre
d'élus évidemment portant portant leur
écharpe
je vous propose qu'on soit peut-être
plusieurs à répondre à la question ce
que mes collègues ont bien sûr
du problème non pas de ce qui s'est
passé après mais ce qui mais pourquoi
nous étions là et le reste on pourra en
parler après et ce qui m'intéresse
beaucoup dans votre question c'est
qu'elle va me permettre d'expliquer le
contexte la psychologie dans laquelle
peuvent se trouver des personnes non
violentes pacifiques qui disent c'est
interdit les gilet quand même et c'est
important de comprendre pourquoi dans ce
cadre précis ils le font là où comme la
CFTC pour plein d'autres cas on aurait
pu ne pas le faire et nous-mêmes on
n'appelle pas des manifs interdites
enfin on attaque parfois les les
décisions d'interdiction évidemment
c'est notre rôle de partie mais voilà le
cas il spécifique la première
spécificité c'est ce cas des bassines et
c'est valable pour beaucoup d'autres
sujets environnementaux
Notre-Dame-des-Landes Civens ce qui
était aussi lié à l'eau d'ailleurs c'est
un moment de notre histoire où on prend
conscience que les procédures juridiques
ne servent plus à rien dire que sur ces
bassines peut-être Benoit tu pourras
faire le point il y a trois pages de
tableau tous les recours sur le sujet on
a l'expérience du fait que les référés
environnementaux qu'on peut faire il y a
d'ailleurs une un rapport de 2021 de
Naïma muchu de horizon et de Cécile
Hunter Meyer du PS qui sont pas
écologistes et qui en 2021 après une
mission flash d'information acte la même
chose que nous de dire ces référents
environnementaux ça ne marche pas
souvent au moment du référé il y a pas
de décision de suspendre mais des années
après quand c'est juju au fond on
suspend souvent trop tard le projet a
commencé même parfois terminé et il
existe et donc il y a des atteintes
environnementales irrémédiable qui sont
faites qui sont illégales du coup mais
jugés illégal trop tard et donc il y a
cette forme de déni de justice qui est
ressentie par beaucoup je donne un
exemple si Vince
s'il n'y avait pas eu la ZAD à silence
et je dis même et c'est dur pour nous de
le dire mais si Rémi Fraisse n'était pas
mort
il y a eu 20 fois plus de grenades
tirées à sainte-solines que le soir de
la mort de Rémi fraise d'ailleurs si
Rémi Fraisse n'était pas mort il y
aurait un barrage à silence aujourd'hui
il a été il y a quelques temps déclaré
illégal et n'a pas été construit mais si
il y avait pas eu ce coup d'arrêt dans
les travaux il aurait été construit et
jugé illégal trop tard c'est un exemple
parmi beaucoup d'autres et donc déjà il
y a cette forme de sentiment de déni de
justice et quand vous êtes écho anxieux
parce que moi je répète souvent que les
enfants qui naissent en 2023 on ne sait
pas leur garantir l'habitabilité de la
planète pour quand ils ont 30 ans c'est
pas moi qui le dit en tant que colo
c'est un consensus scientifique inédit
dans l'histoire de l'humanité le GIEC et
donc quand vous avez ça bien en tête que
vous regardez pas ailleurs tous les
jours vous allez ça en tête et que vous
voyez que les la nature continue à être
attaquée le vivant continuait à être
broyer dans l'indifférent général que
vous faites appel au à la justice ça ne
marche pas bon après vous faites les
manifestations on a beaucoup manifesté
d'ailleurs pour la retraite on a vu que
on avait aussi beaucoup de mal à
convaincre en tout cas dans les années
qui viennent on aura beaucoup de mal à
convaincre que les manifestations aussi
pas être utile et donc il y a ce
contexte et puis il y a un autre
contexte c'est celui de la crimination
des mouvements écolos les manifs de
Sainte-Soline les quatre précédentes en
fait il y en a eu quatre à Sainte Soline
les quatre ont été interdites dire qu'il
y a un sentiment aussi je vous dis pas
c'est sûr c'est ça je vous dis il y a un
sentiment c'est comme le sentiment
d'insécurité c'est forcément subjectif
mais il y a un sentiment chez beaucoup
de militants plutôt jeune plutôt pas des
militants politiques d'ailleurs mais
c'est de plus en plus fort que en fait
on
on veut pas qu'on parle du sujet dire
que une manifestation bonne enfant ou ça
se passe très bien etc en fait ça permet
de faire parler du sujet parce que tout
le week-end à la télé on dit tiens il se
rassemblement comment ça va se passer
que cetera on en veut pas donc il faut
interdire la manif premièrement je vous
parle pas de celle de sainte-soulina ou
des dangers étaient annoncés réels et on
y reviendra mais pour les premières on
dit bah tiens ils veulent pas que la
manifestio et qu'elle se passe bien
parce que l'interdiction à deux effets
premièrement évidemment de la dissuasion
à ne pas y aller c'est le but chercher
et deuxièmement on pressant que ça a pas
très bien se passer donc il y a toujours
cette angoisse et puis aussi on sait que
ça se termine par des images pas cool
qui servent pas notre récit politique et
donc dans ces cas là vous avez deux
choix là je parle pas de moi je parle
des gens qui ont été à la 1 quand même
la 2 la 3 moi j'étais qu'au deux
dernières qui disent bah voilà ils
veulent pas qu'on fasse on nous empêche
et donc ils se sentent attaqués dans
leur liberté même de manifester je
souligne que j'ai participé à beaucoup
de manifestations mais si la station des
soulèvements de la terre on n'a pas du
tout participé à l'organisation de
celle-ci pas du tout on n'était pas dans
les organisateurs ELV on était
participant on avait appelé cette manif
on n'a pas appelé à la manif après
l'interdiction on a fait voilà de la
gestion de militants qui avaient prévu
qui était déterminé à y aller mais le en
mai par exemple David Corman était
présent on a fait les soulèvements de la
terre à Rouen j'ai emmené mon fils de 4
ans ils ont fabriqué des jumelles en une
autre papier toilette pour voir les
oiseaux dans les arbres qu'on allait
sauver contre le grand contournement Est
qui depuis 50 ans défait la chronique et
qui se fera jamais donc les soulèvements
de la terre c'est pas les images qu'on a
vu à BFM de sainte Soline c'est pas ça
c'est des dizaines d'actions qui se
passent très bien c'est 150000 personnes
c'est beaucoup plus vaste que ça mais il
y a un système politique au médiatique
qui fait aussi que c'est ça l'image que
les gens en tête ça imprime il y a aussi
ce contexte donc de criminations des
moments écolos je vous montre suite aux
éco terroriste de Darmanin donc qui
était en octobre 2022 les unes de la
presse
quand vous lisez je vous ai pas militant
vous n'êtes pas ça vous lisez la fraise
vous avez les écolos radicaux quand
l'écologie s'aborde ultra ultra écolo
jusqu'où ira la violence donc les
militants ils se sentent aussi
prisonniers de cette image mais en
disant mais si la concurrence qu'elle
doit plus jamais manifester en fait ils
ont gagné aussi donc il y a ce truc
compliqué
la veille vous avez raison il y avait
une ambiance bon enfant comme dans
toutes les autres manifestations les
soulèvements de la terre que j'ai pu
faire
mais c'est pas vrai que les inquiétudes
ont monté la veille elles montaient
depuis des semaines depuis des semaines
puisque il y avait des annonces
testostéroney du ministre de l'Intérieur
sûrement basé sur des craintes réelles
mais disons qu'il y en a quand même
rajouté quand vous dites il y aura 3200
forces de l'ordre il y aura des drones
il y aura six hélicoptères il y aura
autant de grenades et en fait il dit et
vous verrez il y aura des images
vraiment horribles qu'est-ce que font
les gens ils attendent devant la télé on
a l'impression que ces images quelque
part elles étaient souhaitées nous on ne
les souhaite pas mais on voit qu'il y a
cette tension autour de si de la tente
médiatique et on sait il y a une forme
de Riot porn on l'a tous vécu devant
notre télé quand il y a des manifs et
tout premiers mots on reste clacher
comme ça que c'est toujours la même la
poubelle qui brûle on la regarde des
heures la même image qui tourne en
boucle on est un peu scotché il y a un
truc comme ça un phénomène médiatique
qu'on comprend aussi et donc il y a
pendant ces semaines cette tension qui
monte et donc oui on est inquiet on est
inquiet mais on en discute entre nous on
se dit
cette manie va avoir lieu c'était 30 000
manifestants c'est pas bon il y a des
chips selon la police il y avait pas la
CGT mais selon les participants ce sont
des ornithologues qui comptent au clic
et c'est leur métier de compter du
vivant au clip normalement ils savent le
faire 30 000 personnes c'est le plus
gros rassemblement écolo en France
depuis le Larzac c'est ça qui a annoncé
et donc on sait que les gens vont y
aller ils ont prévu leur salle de
couchage leur tente le covoiturage ils
vont y aller et donc qu'est-ce qu'on
fait chez nous et on laisse les 200
manifestants dont peut-être les parents
vont nous appeler inquiet donc ça bah
non on doit être là et donc on y va en
espérant que ça se passera au mieux en
se disant on pourra faire des choses sur
place évidemment qu'il y a des gens qui
viennent dans cette manifestation si tu
as annoncé pas pour les bassines mais
pour la confrontation ils sont pas des
soulèvements de la terre ils sont pas de
rap Écologie Les Verts à ma connaissance
peut-être que des gens des infos que je
n'ai pas mais dans tous les mémoires en
défense du Minister à l'intérieur je
n'ai rien vu de tangible comme preuve et
donc on les voit aussi enfin on voit
bien enfin on sait bien mais quand vous
allez au 1er mai
je sais pas si vous manifestez le 1er
mai nous on manifeste le 1er mai on les
voit aussi j'ai jamais vu une
interdiction de manif le 1er mai j'ai
jamais vu Sophie Binet et Marylise Léon
ou Martinez hébergé avant être menacé de
dissolution parce qu'il y a des Black
Blocs qui sont venus à la manie du
premier mai donc c'est comme ça que ça
se passe ensuite vous dites on voit bien
sur le terrain la confrontation elle
peut être que volontaire là je suis pas
d'accord j'ai pas moi je suis pas
experte scientifique de commission
d'enquête de post manifestation mais
quand on lit le rapport de la LDH on se
rend compte quand même que les ça pas ça
part pas en live dans une confrontation
très direct physique ça part ça part à
distance il y a un feu d'artifice qui
est tiré comme il y en a dans plein de
manifs qui arrivent à distance des
forces de l'ordre mais qui sûrement se
sentent menacer et qui répliquent et
c'est comme ça que ça s'embrasse nous on
n'est pas là à ce moment-là on est au
fond du cortège parce que Julien Legay
qui vous dites pourquoi ça s'est mal
passé que les organisateurs ils ont pas
bien discuté avant de toutes les règles
de sécurité bon il se trouve que nous
dans les n'étaient pas mais Julien
Leguet qui lui en était il est en garde
à vue pendant 48 heures quand même avant
la manif une semaine avant il est
interdit de territoire à sainte-soliner
il est il a un mouchard sur sa voiture
son neveu se fait tabasser agressé très
violemment quelques quelques semaines
avant et donc non il y a pas de
confiance mais pas juste à cause des
manifs à cause de l'eau à cause des
bassines à cause des autorisations
préfectorales de faire les bassines et
pas de manifester pour tout ça donc il y
a pas de ouais non il y a pas de
confiance localement entre les
organisateurs et les autorités je pense
que c'est manifeste et que c'est pas lié
qu'à ce jour-là toujours est-il que ça
pas été bien préparé ensemble et
sûrement pas sur le plan des secours
nous y reviendrons et donc nous quand on
arrive puisqu'on est en fin de cortège
qu'en plus on dit au revoir à Julien
Legay qui arrivait au panneau sainte
Soline ne peut pas pénétrer sur la
commune qu'il attend au panneau on lui
dit au revoir on est dans le cortège des
derniers qui arrivent quand on arrive
les camions sont des gens en fan etc ce
qu'on peut vous dire c'est que moi je
veux pas entendre les gens qui ont été
blessés sur place il l'avait bien
cherché parce qu'ils avaient pas être là
et puis en plus si ils ont été blessés
c'est qu'ils étaient en première ligne
nous n'étions pas en première ligne on
était vraiment au fond quand on arrivait
avec ce camion qui brûle on est arrivé
donc en fait vous avez le pour que vous
situiez ce chant que vous avez été sur
place je sais plus où j'ai mis le plan
mais en fait vous avez ce grand champ
ce n'est que des champs vous avez cette
bassine et nous sommes là dans le
triangle orange et donc il y a une
fanfare qui joue et nous on se dit c'est
peut-être le syndrome du Titanic on se
dit on va se mettre près de la fanfare
normalement les forces de l'ordre vont
se rendre compte que ceux qui sont
autour de la fanfare tout se passe bien
et c'est là qu'on nous dit que les quads
arrivent alors moi je comprends pas ce
que c'est que c'est quoi que je savais
pas qu'il y avait des militaires à quoi
de sur ce terrain et je sens une panique
vraiment
des gens paniquent il y a des quads qui
arrivent ils reviennent parce qu'en fait
on apprend plus tard qu'ils étaient déjà
venus au début que c'est là que la
confrontation a commencé les quads c'est
l'équivalent brave m de la ruralité quoi
c'est dans tous les rapports de notre
rapport gendarmerie rapport LDH rapport
préfet Dispa les mêmes trucs ils avaient
pas le droit de tirer le Bd ah bah s'ils
l'ont fait quand même sans autorisation
assis en fait il nous l'avait dit mais
on s'en rappelait plus fin on n'a jamais
compris trop dans lequel 4 de l'égalité
ils opéré ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils
sont arrivés sur nous par derrière pas
par devant ou était l'erreur mais par
derrière donc clairement les personnes
avec qui sont confrontés étaient les non
violents qui étaient le plus à l'arrière
que quand on nous a dit qu'ils
arrivaient on nous a dit il y a plein de
baissés entreposés à l'arrière de la
première charge où on n'était pas il
faut aller les protéger que Benoît qui
est un habitude c'est manifestations a
pris un peu le lui dans 10 ans ceux qui
ont des écharpes ce n'est pas mon cas je
suis pas député mettez-vous devant bien
visibles parce qu'ils vont à toute
allure mais ils vont voir avec nos
écharpes que là c'est les élus et les
blessés et de s'approche et nous tire
dessus
et le ministère de l'Intérieur la
préfète diront pendant des jours que
c'était faux donc on tient votre
disposition des photos tout ça on a
toutes les preuves et donc tout ça pour
vous montrer que nous étions non
violents nous étions à l'écart des
heures très très nettement encore plus
quand on projet quand on protéger les
blessés et que on a été pris pour cible
asphyxier moi j'ai eu des troubles
auditifs pendant des semaines ensuite
j'ai une grenade qui a éclatée de mon
pied il y avait un journaliste
d'ailleurs présent à côté qui l'a senti
aussi on a dû porter nous-mêmes les
baisers voilà pour vous dire c'est pas
ceux qui vont à la confrontation ils
vont volontairement c'est sûrement vrai
pour certains qui ne sont pas à mon avis
là pour les bassines d'ailleurs comme
dans les manifs du 1er mai ils sont pas
là pour la CGT mais c'est comme ça que
que ça s'est passé donc oui c'est une
escalade d'angoisse et moi ce qui
m'inquiète encore plus c'est que je peux
vous dire que des non-violents très très
convaincus qui vivent ça ça leur donne
pas confiance dans les forces de l'ordre
force de l'ordre gardien de la paix nous
on soutient leur action ils sont
nécessaires et les gens qui font ce
métier moi je comprends que c'est un
métier très dur que pour leur famille
c'est très difficile aussi moi je me
mets aussi à leur place la réalité c'est
que la doctrine une matière de l'ordre
mise en place ce jour là tout autour de
la bassine vous dites ah bah comme il
bougeait pas c'était pas dangereux pour
personne mais si ça l'était ce
contrairement à sainte-solide en octobre
où on a avancé des kilomètres en passant
des barrages de 10 un par un et puis
tout se passait bien
dans plein d'autres manifs ça s'est
passé comme ça là ce truc de de 3000 sur
les 3200 il y en a 3000 qui étaient
autour de la bassine pour protéger un
trou et donc évidemment que ça crée une
confrontation puisque au lieu de que ce
soit éparpillé etc tout le monde va vers
la bassine pour voir ce que c'est qu'une
bassine et là ça c'est c'est ça crée une
confrontation au contraire très direct
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce que ça aurait pu
faire qu'on rentre dans cette bassine
c'est un trou il y a rien à détruire il
y en a les gens seraient restés 20
minutes dans la bassine et c'est reparti
chez eux quoi il y a rien à détruire sur
place donc voilà l'incompréhension de
notre part sur la partie maintien de
l'ordre voilà
peut-être que Benoît tu veux compléter
peut-être David aussi oui effectivement
je pensais que vous vouliez échanger par
rapport à l'intervention de marine juste
avant
juste je vais pas redire tout ce qui a
dit marine j'ai vécu exactement la même
histoire moi je vais peut-être
essayer d'expliquer la chronologie qui
conduit à cette escalade et qui amène à
ce que effectivement il est 30000
citoyens qui un jour
se rassemblent à Sainte Soline pour dire
ce que vous faites avec les bassines ça
ne nous convient pas alors j'ai été
présenté par Florent comme élu régional
j'étais vice-président d'une région
conseiller régional avec Florent ensuite
en nouvelle-aquitaine j'ai été présenté
par Marine non pas exploitant agricole
mais moi je préfère paysans mais
mes paysans paysans c'est bien voilà et
donc j'ai aussi cette cette casquette là
on va dire ça mais dans une autre vie
avant avant tout ça
je suis scientifique et j'étais à
l'époque à la fin des années 90 recruté
par
la France l'État français pour
travailler sur la sortie d'un
contentieux européen sur le dossier
Marais Poitevin précisément sur la
problématique de la gestion de l'eau qui
avait été épinglé par la Commission
européenne et qui est donc avec conduit
à ce contentieux européen
dans ces travaux là à ce moment-là les
études montrent que effectivement la
gestion de l'eau sur ce périmètre du
Marais près de 20 et pas très bonne et
même désastreuse que la gestion la
biodiversité puisque les directives
habitats les directives oiseaux sont
bafouées dans la façon dont on gère ce
territoire
sont pas bonnes non plus et donc on me
demande d'essayer de trouver des
réponses des solutions techniques des
solutions d'aménagement du territoire
pour sortir de cette situation là avec
une anecdote c'est que c'est le seul
parc naturel en France qui perd son
label Accor à cause de ce contentieux
européen ce qu'on appelle parc naturel
régional à la fin des années 90
précisément parce que ce territoire est
mal géré sur ces enjeux de l'eau et de
la biodiversité
rapidement sur les travaux techniques et
scientifiques que je conduis amène donc
à un certain nombre de mesures qui sont
transmis à la Commission européenne par
l'état français pour sortir de ce
contentieux européen dans les
discussions parce que quand on fait ce
travail technique et scientifique il y a
aussi tout un travail de médiation de
consultation de concertation avec les
acteurs du territoire
les approches scientifiques sont sont
pas contestés mais dans la discussion
avec le monde agricole apparaît une
réponse possible au travers des de la
constitution de ces fameuses bassines ce
que j'essaie de vous expliquer c'est que
ces bassines sont reconnus comme une
solution une fois que toutes les autres
solutions ont été mises en oeuvre et que
une fois qu'on a remet André les cours
d'eau qu'on a créé des conditions de
ralentissement de l'eau sur les bassins
versants retenus sur les zones humides
qu'on a replanté des arbres des haies et
que on a tout fait pour que les nappes
souterraines se rechargent parce que
c'est ça la vraie solution c'est c'est
stocker de l'eau au maximum de leur
potentiel dans les nappes souterraines
une fois qu'on a fait ça on peut sur
certaines zones peut-être constatées
encore des déficits et donc avoir besoin
des bassines et c'est seulement à la
lumière de ce constat là qu'on un voyage
les projets de bassine et la raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui on est dans cette
situation là c'est que malgré la
transmission de ces promesses faites par
l'état français à l'Europe qui a permis
de clore définitivement le contentieux
en 2005 qui a permis ensuite d'ailleurs
de retrouver le fameux label parc
naturel régional Florent tu t'en
rappelles c'était à l'époque où
on était tous les deux Conseils
Régionaux c'est
malheureusement
les mesures qui sont proposées dans ce
rapport qui sont pas mis en oeuvre et
ceux qui se passent et c'est la raison
pour laquelle on arrive à des tensions
aussi fortes c'est qu'on appuie tout de
suite sur le basson le bouton
méga bassine retenu de substitution
avant d'avoir mis en oeuvre toutes les
autres solutions et donc on arrive sur
une situation où les méga bassines qui
sont présentés comme un potentiel une
potentielle solution si on aménage bien
le territoire et une fois qu'on l'a bien
aménagé deviennent au contraire et c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est des
scientifiques
deviennent au contraire une une
complication supplémentaire à un déficit
de bonne gestion de l'eau sur ce
territoire là et c'est ça le biais du
raisonnement et là encore c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est et ça nous amène à la
raison pour laquelle on a 30 000
citoyens qui se rassemblent le 25 mars
c'est que à la lumière de ces
connaissances techniques et
scientifiques de ces solutions qui sont
portées par ce rapport et qui ont été
promis par l'état français pour sortir
du contentieux européen quand c'est
premier projet de bassine arrivent qui
d'abord sont au nombre de 19 puis de 16
puisqu'on se rend compte que on a
surdimensionné un peu les projets et que
les premiers recours déposés en justice
sont gagnées par les opposants assez
bassines qui sont pas des opposants à
l'irrigation qui sont pas des opposants
stockage de l'eau mais qui réclament que
si on fait des bassines si on utilise
l'eau de l'irrigation on crée les
conditions de la réussite de ces projets
et c'est ça qui va pas dans ces projets
là et c'est pour ça qu'elle la
résistance et il y a d'autant plus de
résistance que et c'est souvent un angle
mort il y a beaucoup d'argent public sur
la table et que quand il y a beaucoup
d'argent public sur la table les
citoyens sont parfois en résistance
quand ça n'est pas conforme à leurs
attentes et donc les premiers recours
arrivent ils sont gagnés ce qui fait que
on passe de 19 à 16 donc on réduit la
taille du projet mais malgré ça au bout
de 16
au bout de 16 bassines et quand et on
dépose des recours à nouveau sur ce
projet à 16 bassines on gagne à peu près
tous les recours c'est pas à peu près on
les gagne tous il y a en tout cas au 25
mars au moment du rassemblement à
sainte-soling tous les recours déposés
par les opposants par les associations
de protection de la nature et de
l'environnement sont gagnées il y a un
recours qui est perdu mais qui est
actuellement en appel à la Cour d'appel
de Bordeaux qui est postérieure au 25
mars mais pour lequel pour lequel on est
très confiant sur le rendu de la cour
d'appel de Bordeaux et donc ça me
renvoie à des questions c'est à dire que
quand on est citoyen un territoire qu'on
fait le constat que il y a des choses
qui dysfonctionnent que des solutions
techniques et scientifiques sont portées
notamment par ce rapport que j'ai eu le
plaisir de d'animer et qui a été
transmis à la Commission européenne que
malgré les promesses de l'État rien
n'est fait que des recours sont déposés
en justice sont tous gagnés que la
communauté scientifique est à peu près
unanime pour dire que les bassines
peuvent être une bonne réponse mais
uniquement après avoir posé les
préalables qui constituent les
conditions de la réussite d'une bonne
gestion de l'eau sur ce territoire
comment est-ce qu'on fait
quand on est citoyen a fortiori quand on
est élu attaché à la justice attaché à
la démocratie attachée aux valeurs de la
République attachés à l'État de droit et
que malgré ces constats là justice qui
nous donner raison communauté
scientifique qui nous donne raison
manque d'acceptation sociétale avec des
citoyens qui disent on veut pas que
l'argent public aille sur ces sujets là
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour empêcher
des projets qui à ce point télescope ce
que pour on pourrait appeler l'État de
droit quand en plus on nous interdit de
manifester parce que on a quand même une
interdiction de manifester donc moi je
vous pose la question on est plusieurs
élus dans la salle ici comment est-ce
qu'on fait pour quand on est attaché à
l'état de droit réclamer que l'État de
droit soit précisément respecté dans les
décisions telles que le démarrage de
travaux de méga vaccine et Marine a fait
référence
assez recours qui sont gagnées parfois
postériori à la elle a évoqué l'exemple
de Sylvain c'est parce qu'à l'époque
j'étais administrateur de l'Agence de
l'eau à dourgaronne qui était le
principal financeur de Sylvain GT à
six-20 également et effectivement à
posteriori le donc le projet s'est
arrêté pour les raisons que vous
connaissez je vais pas revenir
c'est d'ailleurs un peu traumatisant
quand on a vécu Sylvain c'est qu'on
était là le jour où Rémi Fraisse est
décédé
et que on revit sainte Soline il y a des
choses qui remontent c'est évident mais
le constat c'est que le projet s'est
arrêté la procédures en justice ont
continué et que le projet de Sylvain
c'est qu'il était présenté n'était pas
dans la légalité sur le projet des méga
bassines sur le marais poitevin on a
déjà des des comment dire du recul sur
la non conformité de ces projets avec
les réglementations en vigueur en France
et en Europe puisque les cinq bassines
de la laine tranche avant qui ont été
financés par de l'argent public sont
aujourd'hui parfaitement illégales
c'est-à-dire que le Conseil d'État qui
est la plus grosse la plus haute
juridiction pardon de de notre
République à définitivement dit que ces
cinq bassines n'étaient pas construites
en conformité avec les réglementations
en vigueur en France et en Europe
donc cette stratégie qui consiste à
avancer au rouleau compresseur à imposer
à des citoyens qui payent des impôts que
leur argent public aille sur des projets
qui une fois qui sont terminés sont
déboutés par la justice et donc cette
stratégie d'être mis devant le fait
accompli suscite effectivement de la
Résistance et de la réaction de la part
des citoyens suicide de la Résistance et
de la réaction chez les militants
écologistes et je répète je repose ma
question comment est-ce qu'on fait quand
on est dans cette situation là à part se
rassembler que des citoyens pour
manifester notre désapprobation
je voulais juste faire un petit je vais
très bref j'ai eu le plaisir d'être
parmi ceux qui étaient auditionnés au
Conseil d'État pour
la décision ou pas de maintenir la
dissolution des soulèvements de la terre
et le débat a tourné beaucoup autour de
cette définition de la violence
et vous avez vu la communication du
Conseil d'État mais mes cheveux revenir
là-dessus c'est la violence et c'est
quand effectivement les personnes les
êtres vivants sont atteintes par des
gestes qui qu'on peut qualifier de
violence la désobéissance civile c'est
autre chose c'est des gestes symboliques
c'est des actions symboliques qui n'ont
pas d'impact majeur sur l'économie qui
n'ont pas d'impact sur le fonctionnement
de de l'État et en vérité quand on se
lance dans la désobéissance civile on
accepte la judiciarisation qui va avec
mais c'est pour attirer l'attention
c'est grâce à la désobéissance civile
qu'on n'a pas un grand parc militaire au
Larzac c'est grâce à la désobéissance
civile qu'on n'a pas le barrage de
silence c'est grâce à la désobéissance
civile qu'on n'a pas de gaz de schiste
en France ces gaz grâce à la
désobéissance civile qu'on n'a pas d'OGM
en France donc la liste est extrêmement
longue et donc
retenir que cette cette façon de lutter
et aussi un outil qui peut servir
l'intérêt commun et l'avenir des
générations futures et puis ma dernière
chose c'est que tu as évoqué la violence
faite aux écologistes marines je
rappelle hasard du calendrier que le 27
ou le 28 mars Michel forces qui est
rapporteur spécial à l'ONU sur la
protection des défenseurs de
l'environnement a publié un rapport ou
il manifeste sa vive inquiétude sur
l'attitude et la violence proposée aux
défenseurs de l'environnement y compris
dans notre pays surtout dans notre pays
puisque ce rapport a été très ciblé sur
la France et donc voilà je je vous
invite à attirer enfin j'attire votre
attention sur cette partie là des choses
quand on est député européen on regarde
aussi la presse à l'étranger
on sort de la presse nationale et le
regard de la presse étrangère sur ce qui
se passe en France en ce moment le
regard d'un rapporteur spécial à l'ONU
devrait quand même attirer notre
attention sur ce qui est en train de se
passer dans ce pays
juste pour préciser qu'on tient à votre
disposition du coup le tableau de tous
les recours gagnés sur enfin contre ses
bassines
que la mission flash de 2021 du coup
avait fait beaucoup de propositions
transpartisanes pour remédier à cela
aucune n'a été suivi des faits et que
vous parliez du Lot-et-Garonne où
j'avais été prise pour cible pourquoi
Serge Bousquet Cassagne le président de
la coordinationale de ce département
était très énervé deux trois jours après
sainte Soline c'est qu'il pensait moi
j'allais aider sur une maternité qui
était menacée de fermeture à
Villeneuve-sur-Lot lui il a cru quand il
a su que je venait que je venais pour
son histoire de lac de Caussade pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas le lac de
cossat c'est une retenue d'eau illégale
qu'il a construit pendant il a profité
du covid pour pour avancer que quand on
demande aux autorités pourquoi c'est
interdit réinterdit réinterdit et que
non seulement il a creusé quasiment
lui-même et en plus elle fonctionne
tranquillement depuis on me dit ah bah
vous le connaissez pas il s'est mobilisé
des agriculteurs et des chasseurs et il
a fait reculer des bataillons entiers de
gendarmerie donc pour des raisons de de
tranquillité publique il faut mieux
qu'on laisse faire d'ailleurs on vous
conseille de pas venir parce qu'il est
dangereux et donc j'attendais moi en
France je peux pas aller dans le lot de
Garonne parce que ah oui ils ont des
fusils mais ils vont faire quoi ils vont
me fusiller non mais ils peuvent tirer
en l'air très dangereux vous rendez pas
compte du personnage bah si mais du coup
je vais venir voir par moi-même y
compris en soutien les collègues locaux
parce que si la chef du Parti dit moi je
vais pas dans le Lot-et-Garonne c'est
trop compliqué qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire pour les gens qui menacent de mort
au quotidien et il m'a menacé moi pas
sur son assaut je sais pas quoi il m'a
menacé sur du papier à en tête de la
Chambre d'Agriculture qu'il préside
c'est un établissement public il est
encore président de la Chambre
d'Agriculture donc ça c'est pour le deux
poids de mesure et vous dire que
malheureusement il y a on parlait de la
désobéissance civile mais il y en a qui
désobéissent de manière pas du tout
civile plutôt très agressive et qu'il
obtienne gain de cause dans ce pays et
que je peux vous faire la liste de tout
ce qu'a fait la FNSEA comme action alors
il y a de la désobéissance civile des
belles pailles près de la préfecture on
serre la main on dit oui on va on va
être attentif etc mais il y a ils ont
incendié le le centre des impôts de
Morlaix en 2014 ils ont écrasé des
ragondins avec un tracteur devant la
préfecture de chez Piou ça devait être
dans le coin aussi de notre ami il y a
là l'Office de la biodiversité quelques
jours après sainte Soline qui est pris
pour cible c'était pas des c'était pas
la FNSEA mais par des fusées et qui
brûle à moi en grande partie et en fait
le lendemain le ministre de
l'Agriculture il est au congrès de la
FNSEA il y a pas un seul mot dire si on
va aller dissoudre etc et moi si j'étais
ministre de l'intérieur ou l'un d'entre
nous de l'intérieur de l'écriture ou
quoi que ce soit on va pas dissoudre la
FNSEA on l'a d'autres moyens dans ce
pays de régler ses conflits politiques
que de dissoudre les gens en fait on
n'est pas dans le Roundup donc du coup
c'est important pour nous quand on vit
on veut apaiser se parler c'est très
important pour nous et je crois Daniel
t'avais un exemple de dossier sur lequel
montrer comment ça se passe sur plein de
dossiers en France et sur lesquels ça
peut partir comme ça en incompréhension
et donc en violence malheureusement
alors je me permets juste de commentaire
l'objectif c'est qu'on puisse recentrer
sur notamment le la question des des
manifestations parce que sinon comment
dire débat pourrait très longtemps non
non mais évidemment on est bien on est
bien d'accord moi je effectivement ton
dolier vous on est on est preneur de du
tableau par rapport à ce qui a pu être
dit et pour éclairer la commission
d'enquête
sur Sainte solide au mois de mars donc
le la préfète prend un arrêté donc
préfectoral d'interdiction de
manifestation
pour prendre un tel arrêté vous pouvez
pas juste prendre l'arrêté il faut le
justifier c'est-à-dire dans un état de
droit et d'ailleurs la jurisprudence est
constante et d'ailleurs il y a des
recours qui peuvent être faits lorsque
comment dire il n'y a pas de
justification suffisante la question est
simple est-ce que vous avez engagé un un
recours contre l'interdiction de
manifester et si c'est le cas est-ce que
est-ce que l'arrêté a été annulé
en fait on l'a pas fait parce qu'on
n'était pas organisateur on l'a fait par
exemple de mémoire pour le bah oui j'en
suis sûr pour la manif du lion Turin qui
a eu lieu après parce que la petite
histoire c'est que nous on nous a
demandé par exemple de co-organiser la
manif du Lyon-Turin parce que après ça
ne solide et quand j'ai vu la première
ministre d'un rendez-vous très officiel
elle nous avait demandé de venir parti
par partie et évidemment c'était
quelques jours après donc on a beaucoup
parlé de ça il nous a été suggéré que ce
serait peut-être mieux qu'on co-organise
les prochaines manifestations justement
pour jouer ce rôle de parti politique
habitué depuis des années à organiser
des manifestations et malheureusement
enfin moi je me rappelle d'opération
César aussi à notre âme des Landes ou
c'était aussi ultraviolant et qui est à
nos dépenses mais en fait on a
l'expérience de ça et de faire en sorte
que ça se passe le mieux possible et
donc il nous a été demandé si possible
pour que ça se passe mieux les
prochaines fois de co-organiser ce que
nous avons fait pour le lion Turin voilà
mais mais là on n'était pas coordinateur
donc on avait pas de volonté de citer de
l'attaquer faut savoir aussi que
le droit c'est beaucoup rigidifier c'est
beaucoup plus simple aujourd'hui
d'attaquer enfin de
veut pas dire des manifestations il y a
plein de raisons de le faire et que par
ailleurs pour le Conseil d'État sur la
dissolution des soulèvements de la terre
on voit bien qu'entre ce qui a annoncé
je vais dissoute demain alors là j'ai un
dossier vous allez voir vous avez pas
être déçu finalement on a le dossier et
l'arrêter deux mois après ça traîne et
puis quand ça arrive au tribunal il y a
rien dedans quoi donc moi je me suis dit
un moment ils ont peut-être des infos
que j'ai pas c'est possible il y a
sûrement des Black Blocs qui ont prévu
de venir ou je sais pas qui que je
connais pas c'est possible d'ailleurs le
rôle de l'État c'est pas dire ah bah
s'il y a un black bloc qui a annoncé on
interdit la manifestation sinon on va
plus beaucoup manifester et pourquoi ils
viennent c'est parce qu'il y a déjà eu
quatre manif et que bah ça s'échauffe
d'édition en édition et donc celui qui
veut prendre rendez-vous avec avec la
confrontation il sait que c'est là que
ça va se passer et pour la même raison
d'ailleurs je précise il y avait une
manifestation anti-nucléaire prévue à
Bures le premier week-end de juin que on
co-organisait
les locaux nous avait dit nous on a peur
de dépasser on a trop peur après sainte
Soline on ne sait pas le faire en plus
dur c'est la forêt il y a déjà eu des
manifestations qui sont très mal
terminées là-bas
je repasse la parole à Monsieur
rapporteur oui merci monsieur le
Président de remarques deux questions la
première sur les soulèvements de la
terre si je me trompe pas
l'argumentation du Conseil d'État
consiste à dire il n'y a pas assez
d'éléments pour démontrer que des
agissements individuels peuvent être
raccrochés à une structure collective
qui d'ailleurs est le résultat d'une
disposition législative nous avons
adapté adopté ici et ça c'est toute la
difficulté de pouvoir donner des preuves
de l'appartenance d'un individu à une
organisation qui elle-même n'est pas une
organisation
donc c'est pas tout à fait ce que vous
avez dit c'est que l'État vous répondrez
après l'état n'arrive pas au Conseil
d'État faute de tout avec rien du tout
entre les mains il n'arrive pas à
démontrer le lien entre les agissements
n'ont pas entre les agissements et les
individus ça c'est démontré mais entre
les individus et une organisation qui
elle-même est une organisation floue peu
structurée par nature et personne ne dit
d'ailleurs que l'ensemble des personnes
qui gravitent ou militer ou continue de
méditer au soulèvement de la terre
appartiennent à des groupuscules
violents simplement il y a des liens
individuels en tout cas c'est ce que
l'État a voulu démontrer que le Conseil
d'État n'a pas accepté faute de
motivation mais c'est sur cet élément là
que le Conseil d'État motive et qui est
vraiment essentiel je le rappelle c'est
une disposition légative que nous avons
adopté au moins la précédente il faut
que je t'ai rapporté du texte deuxième
remarque et là nous devrons vérifier je
le dis sous le contrôle du président
administrateur quand on est sur place on
nous dit il y a pas 3000 personnes
autour de l'infrastructure méga bassine
non il y a 3000 personnes sur une zone
beaucoup plus vaste
non mais c'est parce que
alors si vous considérez que BFM TV si
vous considérez dans le jeu alors si
vous considérez que BFM TV source
policière vaut en soit information nous
en tout cas modestement la commission
d'enquête dans nos considérons pas que
BFM TV est une source sûre pardon pour
BFM TV si nous regardent sur le canal
mais en tout cas les informations dont
nous disposons à ce stade ce sont 3000
forces de l'ordre sur une zone bien plus
vaste qui consiste à sécuriser d'autres
retenues ou d'autres bassines ou
d'autres méga bassines j'emploie tous
les termes possibles Imaginales dont la
moitié autour de l'infrastructure
principale qui a fait l'objet
d'affrontement deux questions par contre
cette fois-ci
moi j'attire votre attention sur un
élément
en posant la question vous avez voulu
nous renseigner je comprends très bien
sur la psychologie militante y compris
un centre d'individus qui considère
qu'il y a un risque vital
pour leur existence même sur les
questions environnementales l'eau
notamment mais pas que
j'attire votre attention que votre
argumentation au fond je trouve qu'elle
donne du crédit et je le regrette à
celles et ceux qui ne sont pas de votre
sensibilité politique mais qui sont
représentés à l'Assemblée nationale qui
considère contre vous et les violences
il y a un continuum
et je trouve cet argumentation
dangereuse à partir du moment où
considérez que un militant arrive avec
une colère phénoménale qui peut
justifier un certain nombre de tolérance
à la violence voire même d'action
violente je trouve que vous justifiez
l'idée d'un continuum qui me paraît
délicat y compris pour la crédibilité de
nos partis politiques je ne jugerai pas
de la vôtre ce n'est pas le sujet
deuxième question si vous aviez été
co-organisateur
de la manifestation du mois de mars
est-ce que vous l'auriez annulé
l'histoire la vraie me suffit parce
qu'avec des si on refait le monde et
enfin je sais pas quelle émergent entre
les mains je sais pas si on en serait
arrivé là d'ailleurs dans le enfin j'en
sais rien en fait je veux pas faire
semblant mais mais
j'ai ma question je m'appuie sur le fait
que vous avez noté
l'organisation du manifestation avec des
risques qui sont remontés à vous en tant
qu'organisateur qui vous ont
poussé par annuler cette manifestation
la contenu des éléments de risque que
vous connaissiez puisque vous avez il y
avait des risques ont courus il y avait
des symptômes d'éléments plusieurs
semaines avant moi j'ajoute que la
veille il y a des signes cette fois-ci
physique sur place qui montrait qu'il y
avait des individus violents présents
est-ce que vous auriez considéré
utile si vous aviez été coordinateur ce
n'est pas de la politique fiction compte
tenu des éléments dont vous aviez
connaissance à l'époque ce n'est pas de
la politique fiction est-ce que vous
auriez annulé cette manifestation je dis
pas ça pour fuir votre question c'est
juste qu'en fait si on avait été
coordinateur on aurait peut-être pas été
dans la même situation la veille pas
parce qu'on est des génies de la
médiation mais parce que premièrement on
aurait dialogué avec les autorités ce
qu'on fait tout le temps et ce qu'on a
fait sur les autres manifestations parce
qu'on a fait même après insoline avec la
première ministre etc ou même pendant la
manifestation pour essayer de faire
venir des secours donc il y aurait pas
eu cette incommunicabilité et donc si on
a vu les mêmes éléments que pour but on
aurait sans doute pris la même décision
après dans le Bur il y a aussi le
traumatisme de Sainte-Souline qui fait
que tout le monde prend aussi beaucoup
plus de précautions et je pense que si
on avait été co-organisateur enfin nous
il nous aurait pas mis en garde à vue
comme Julien Legay à une semaine de la
manifestation ce qu'il aille mieux aussi
beaucoup tout le monde et a dit ah bah
ça c'est pas parti pour bien se passer
on aurait peut-être pas eu autant
d'annonces aussi tous les jours
précédents qui ont créé beaucoup de
tension c'est pour ça que je dis je veux
pas refaire l'histoire c'est pas juste
toute chose égale par ailleurs ça aurait
changé l'histoire mais vous dire dans
quel sens enfin en tout cas quand on a
eu à prendre des décisions de ce genre
on les a prises fermement quand on
devait les prendre
sur le continuum de violence je pense
qu'on s'est mal compris parce que quand
j'ai utilisé le mot continuum des
violences je parlais de continuum de
violence envers les écologistes ce que
je voulais dire par ce mot c'est quand
un ministre de l'Intérieur pas un
opposant politique comme il y en a dans
cette salle qui disent c'est des échos
terroristes moi je suis élu d'opposition
Front national depuis 2014 à
Hénin-Beaumont j'ai que merver truc
toute la journée municipal c'est tous
les mois c'est dangereux en fait pour
les gens parce qu'il y a des gens qui
croient vraiment que je pose des bombes
je sais pas quoi enfin les gens lisent
ils croient quoi là on parle du ministre
de l'Intérieur
et le chef de tout ça il désigne
l'ennemi il dit vous êtes enfin eux là
c'est des écho terroristes notions qui
n'existent même pas dans le droit ni
français ni international les côtés
c'est pour dire des actions terroristes
contre la nature c'est nous c'est plutôt
à l'inverse et donc ça crée un continuum
de violence parce que ça crée de la
violence envers nos militants partout en
France d'où l'Observatoire etc mais sa
légitime aussi une répression jamais vue
20 fois plus de grenades tirées ce
jour-là une par seconde une par seconde
et en fait quand on regarde les images
vous savez de ce colonel V dans le
complément d'enquête qui est suivi par
une caméra tout transparence toute la
journée donc déjà c'est lui qui dit ah
bah merde on s'est trompé de cortège non
les cons c'est pas possible donc c'est
quand même la preuve c'est le chef de
l'opération bien la preuve qu'il y a
quand même des gens qui ont été ciblés
qui n'avaient pas à être ciblés et à son
personne à mourir pour ses idées ou être
blessées dans une manif et deuxièmement
il dit à un moment la moto qui volent
qui l'adversaire est à 1 km y compris
enfin quand vous dites c'est des
terroristes tout ça d'ultra gauche ils
sont tous terroristes bah évidemment que
les consignes qui sont données c'est il
y a l'adversaire c'est la guerre c'est
comme ça sortait les armes de guerre ou
le ministre de l'Intérieur nous a dit
pas du tout bah si d'ailleurs David
comment peut en parler puisque il est il
était concerné aussi par le sujet mais
c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé et
donc ça veut dire que ça légitime en
disant donc répression égale c'est
logique et puis brave français on a fait
ça c'est pour vous protéger donc il y a
une vraie bataille de communication
derrière donc c'est pour ça que je
parlais de continuum de violence après
sur il faut pas expliquer sinon c'est
faire semblant qu'on comprend qu'on est
d'accord et donc sa légitime aux
adversaires vous me demandez si j'ai des
éléments pour expliquer la psychologie
des gens qui vont quand même à la
manifestation donc du coup je réponds et
donc je vous explique non pas ce que je
pense moi qui continuerait pendant des
décennies encore je me le souhaite à
combattre pour l'écologie et dans la
non-violence parce que c'est c'est pas
un truc je décide ou pas d'être violente
c'est dans mon ADN c'est très simple et
la désobéissance civile a comme
condition
ultime là non violence et le fait de ne
pas de de d'être à visage découvert
c'est pas des trucs anonymes cagoulés
c'est des choses très assumées très
revendiquées et la troisième raison
enfin d'être quand même condition c'est
d'être pour l'intérêt général ce qui est
manifestement le cas de tout ce qu'on
fait pour préserver la ressource en eau
je vous explique ce que j'entends quand
j'essaye de discuter avec des personnes
concernées voilà je crois que je
souhaitais simplement réagir pour pour
compléter son questionnement et puis
ensuite on poursuit je crois que
Monsieur Biteau vous jouez aussi réagir
donc je laisse la parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur et puis ensuite
très rapidement là par contre la fin de
votre intervention je comprends mieux et
côté au risque nous allons interroger le
ministre de la terre je suppose que
beaucoup de collègues profiteront de
cette occasion pour lui poser la
question nous avons interrogé ce matin
le garder saut sur le même sujet
sous le contrôle de d'Éric Caron
non quand je parlais de quand vous
donnez des éléments
qui effectivement tente de
d'expliquer dans quel psychologie
militante se situe un certain nombre
d'individus bon je ne dis pas que vous
justifiez moi je ne sais pas partie de
ceux qui considèrent qu'expliquaient
c'est justifié bon je ne suis pas de
cette nature là peut-être peut-être je
suis trop modéré de façon générale pour
être dans cette caricature ce que je
considère être comme une caricature je
ne parle pas de ça je dis il me semblait
que vos propos qui justifiaient en
revanche cette fois-ci de façon très
claire votre présence sur place
malgré les risques encourus à propos
vous avez tenu me sembler donner du
crédit à celles et ceux qui veulent voir
dans
quoi le vôtre une fil conducteur entre
votre action politique et des violences
commises c'est ça
et donc je complète ma réponse la même
remarque a été faite à la Ligue des
droits de l'homme
ils avaient le statut d'observatoire
d'observateur qui est un statut reconnu
par le droit international dans tous les
pays dans les zones de guerre partout
mais à Sainte Soline on leur a dénié le
statut d'observateur si je vous donnerai
les textes il y a pas de problème je
vous enverrai par mail et on leur a dit
la même chose mais je voulais juste vous
dire que heureusement que la Ligue des
droits de l'homme est que nous avec
d'autres parlementaires d'ailleurs
d'autres parties étions là parce que
poser la question simplement aux
victimes qui étaient en état d'urgence
absolue combien de temps ça aurait pris
plus les évacuer si on n'avait pas
appelé la terre entière pour essayer de
faire venir des secours et surtout
est-ce qu'on aurait su la vérité et ce
qu'on aurait su la vérité la réponse est
non dans les jours et les heures qui ont
suivi je peux vous montrer mais y
compris le tweet de la de la préfète qui
quand je dis nous étions les élus devant
les blessés nous avons été pris
possibles elle dit c'est faux j'ai la
preuve qu'il y a pas eu de tirs sur les
élus je peux vous montrer les photos ça
c'était la
ça c'était la chaîne humaine que nous
faisions et c'est
lacrymos et vous avez ici la chaîne
avant ça c'est à 13h53 je pense que ça
se voit qu'on est nul pour des gens qui
sont pas trop experts de la politique
même sur un quad normalement on voit des
écharpes blancs rouges on sait que ce
sont des élus et derrière on voit des
blessés allongés ça c'est 3 minutes plus
tard
le ministre de l'intérieur pendant des
jours et des jours jusqu'à ce que je
mette la photo que David Corman peut
vous montrer de lui avec une grenade
au-dessus de sa tête en train de prendre
des photos elle est là ça c'est David
Corman il est bien élu il est bien
député européen ça c'est une grenade
toujours dans ces trois minutes de
l'attaque de quad
jusqu'à ce que je pose cette photo sur
le bureau de la première ministre le
ministre de l'Intérieur a continué à
raconter que il n'y avait pas eu grenade
sur les élus et sur les blessés et si
nous n'avions pas été là avec notre
force d'élus ou de chef de partie pour
le dire l'histoire aurait gardé cette
version il a dit qu'il n'y avait pas
d'armes de guerre l'histoire aurait
gardé cette version et ça c'est je peux
vous dire c'est la double peine parce
que le traumatisme était vraiment
sérieux réel et demeure et quand en plus
pendant des jours et des jours les 30
000 personnes qui étaient présentes en
temps dans la télé des choses fausses du
ministre de l'Intérieur qui est en train
d'écrire son histoire je vous avais
promis des photos des images CQFD et en
plus nous les forces de l'ordre il y a
évidemment qu'il y a des forces de
l'ordre qui ont été attaqués on l'a
toujours condamnés pas juste à Sainte
Soline mais c'est pas la seule histoire
de sans Soline et on m'a demandé de
m'excuser en tant que chef de partie
tous les jours dans chaque émission que
pensez-vous des violences policières
est-ce que vous condamnez à chaque fois
j'ai répondu oui on m'a dit ah bon oui
ah bah non mais c'est bien que vous le
disiez ben j'arrête pas de le dire mais
bon c'est pas grave et j'ai pas de
problème je m'excuserai et je
m'expliquerai je répondrai aux questions
tant qu'il le faudra mais à quel moment
quelqu'un dans ce pays a posé la
question mise de l'intérieur et ce qu'il
regrette les violences subies par des
manifestants et ce qu'il regrette les
scènes que nous avons vécu avec des
milliers d'autres manifestants est-ce
qu'il regrette que des gens entre la vie
et la mort étaient laissés des heures et
des heures dans ce décompte le soir même
il y avait 7 blessés côté manifestant et
donc vous êtes manifestants vous avez vu
passer des corps des des gens qui
portaient des gens dans l'état
n'imaginez même pas toute la journée et
vous rentrez traumatiser le lendemain
vous abîmer la télé la chaîne que vous
voulez et vous voyez Darmanin qui dit il
y a pas eu d'arme de guerre vous vous
êtes pris sur vous quand même vous les
voyez il fallait comme Benoît bitonisé
regardez le ciel il y a pas eu d'arme de
guerre il dit
il n'y a pas eu de il y a eu 7 blessés
seulement voilà par contre les manches
les forces de l'ordre elles ont été
attaquées par des assauts d'extrême
gauche ils étaient tous des milliers de
de radicalisés alors que c'était une
minorité parmi 30 000 manifestants et
donc comprenez que c'est c'est
pas surmonter l'épreuve par exemple et
donc moi j'aimerais qu'un jour j'entende
parce que c'est pas le seul responsable
evidemment qu'il y a beaucoup de
responsabilités dans ce qui s'est passé
à Sainte-Soline mais il peut pas s'en
exonéré et surtout pas en tant que
ministre de l'Intérieur et je n'entends
pas beaucoup de monde lui poser la
question en tout cas j'ai jamais entendu
répondre
juste un point de précision par rapport
à ce qu'on a entendu hier à partir du
moment où vous avez un organisateur qui
comment dire ne n'échange pas avec les
autorités pour permettre la mise en
place d'un certain nombre de choses
d'ailleurs c'est très intéressant ce que
vous dites madame vous dites sans doute
qu'un certain nombre de choses ce serait
passé différemment donc vous voyez bien
que le fait même qu'il y ait une
organisation qui n'établit pas et
d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit vous avez dit
vous-même tiens c'est intéressant parce
que nous on a l'habitude d'établir le
lien avec les autorités pour permettre
oui mais en tout cas de permettre à ce
moment-là l'intervention des services
d'urgence donc vous voyez bien que il y
a un vrai paradoxe y compris dans le
dans le récit et vous comprenez bien que
nous on ne cherche pas à
juxtaposer des récits ce que nous
cherchons à un moment donné à faire
c'est d'essayer d'objectiver le rôle
d'une commission d'enquête par de la nos
différences c'est d'objectiver
aller vers le réel et la vérité et c'est
vrai que là comment dire on se dit qu'il
y a un certain nombre de points sur
lesquels et bien en tout cas des choses
devront être éclaircies et nous ne
rentrons pas et on est bien d'accord
aussi dans la partie judiciaire puisque
demain il y a un procès qui s'ouvre à
Niort où vous serez sur sur place ça
n'est pas notre rôle de nous substituer
à la justice on est bien dans une
commission d'enquête parlementaire sur
le fait qu'aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de de phénomènes violents permettent en
fait que je dirais le la démocratie et
l'état de droit s'exprime je dirais
normalement alors sur la question
vraiment des soins parce que celle que
vous posez et des organisateurs qui
seraient responsables nous on peut vous
dire que heureusement que les
organisateurs étaient là au moment où ça
s'est très mal passé parce que la seule
ambulance qui venait chercher les
blessés quand on l'appelait c'était
c'était la leur plus des véhicules de
participants de particuliers qui
venaient qui
les sièges du scéniques et qui partaient
ça marchait pour les blessés léger
évidemment celle dans nos occupions
cette jeune de 19 ans n'était clairement
pas transportable
dans tous les pays
que des consignes avaient été données
aux manifestants avant que la
manifestation ne démarre en disant ne
vous faites ne faites pas appel au
secours officiel mais
demandez à ce que ce soit les secours
des organisateurs et que vous soyez
transporté le plus loin possible de
sainte Soline est-ce que ce sont des
choses que vous avez entendu ou pas mais
c'est intéressant que vous nous posez
cette question parce que du coup on peut
éclaircir certains faits moi ce truc
c'est pas moi qui l'ai rédigé et j'ai
compris ça sur place quand plusieurs
blessés m'ont dit moi je veux pas aller
à l'hôpital ou pas dans cette région je
demandais pourquoi et on me disait parce
que et on sait en y était en octobre
2022 après Sainte-Souline 3 des gens qui
étaient qui étaient dans hospitalisé
dont un qui avait subi un tir de LBD à
la tête ça appelle quelques histoires
récentes ont été mis en garde à vue à
l'hôpital c'est qu'ils allaient on les
conduisait à l'hôpital pour qu'il se
soigne et que la police est venue faire
des perquisitions à l'hôpital est venu
chercher des listes de blessés de tous
les blessés des hôpitaux ça a été fait
aussi ce weekend là ils arrivent à
l'hôpital ils demandaient la liste de
tous les blessés de l'hôpital et ils
essayaient de faire le lien entre les
blessures et demander aux personnels
soignants dans une violation totale de
secret médical qui a énormément choqué
le personnel soignant est-ce que vous
pouvez nous indiquer quelles blessures
sont susceptibles de provenir de sainte
Soline genre éclat aux membres
inférieurs de Grenade par exemple puis
ils ont été passés vous savez à ce
détecteur c'est les marqueurs comment
c'est des marqueurs chimiques pour des
produits qui ont été utilisés par la
première fois dans cette manif donc
c'est des substances qui sont balancées
donc quand vous passez à la lampe torche
là ça fait une couleur ils ont été faire
ça sur les affaires des gens à l'hôpital
et donc après c'est leur travail dans
lequel ils estiment que c'est légitime
de faire ça ok mais comprenez que
quelqu'un parce que c'était du manif
interdite vous l'avez souligné donc être
là c'était interdit et évidemment que
dans la Pan
et ils vont pas dire non mais c'est à
cause de Julien Leguet qui je sais pas
quoi c'est le droit international donc
c'est très simple c'est dans la déjà la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
dans l'article 2 qui dit pas il faut
soigner quand on peut c'est une
obligation positive c'est de la
responsabilité des États que de faire ça
et c'est même le cas pour les personnes
arrêtées ou détenues je le précise et le
deuxième texte c'est la Convention de
Genève dans son article 8 qui dit je
vais vous lire chaque fois que les
circonstances me permettront et
notamment après un engagement toutes les
mesures possibles seront prises sans
retard sans retard pour rechercher
recueillir les blessés les malades les
naufragés les protéger contre le pillage
les mauvais traitements et leur assurer
les soins appropriés ainsi que pour
rechercher les morts empêcher qu'ils
soient dépouillés etc et donc nous les
cas sur lesquels on a appelé la du côté
de la moi j'ai changé que avec la
préfète et la gendarmerie j'ai le compte
rendu total de nos échanges que j'ai
fait la nuit même en rentrant d'ailleurs
en train avec David Corman pour pour
être sûr de ne rien oublier en reprenant
le journal d'appel les heures parce que
je savais améliorer les enquêtes et je
voulais dire la vérité en toute
transparence je l'ai envoyé le lendemain
au service de la première minute au
directeur de Camille Gérald Darmanin à
la presse le même document et aux
organisateurs en disant c'est ma version
c'est ce que moi j'ai vu ça vaut pas
vérité de tout ce qui était sur site
puisque nous étions avec deux victimes
et pas avec avec Serge en l'occurrence
mais voilà donc ça je l'ai fait en toute
transparence et j'ai l'intégrité de ces
appels nous nous avons discuté avec eux
pour faire venir des secours officiels
et donc bien pour aller à l'hôpital vu
l'état des personnes qu'on assistait et
la LDH a appelé elle le SAMU et c'est le
SAMU qui leur disait qu'il pouvait pas
venir qu'ils attendaient un ordre qui
arrivait très lentement alors qu'entre
14h08 et 15h08 tous les déroulés les
nôtres les dash tout concorde il y a eu
une trêve il n'y a pas eu un seul
incident entre 14h08 et 15h08 après
c'est quoi de la de 13h53 et que pendant
une heure Serge a attendu entre la vie
et la mort que on laisse passer des
pompiers que nous nous voyons loin et
qui était bloqué par des forces de
l'ordre et c'est pas de la force des
forces de l'ordre qui est c'est pas de
la faute d'effort de l'autre qui a piqué
une consigne moi j'ai senti la préfète
très bah évidemment que c'est un moment
dur pour elle et je pense pas que que
elle était complètement insensible à
tout ça mais elle avait peur de de
d'affrontement qui reprennent elle a
attendu très longtemps de donner cet
ordre toujours est-il que c'est elle qui
a donné cet ordre et c'est ça la
responsabilité et la sienne pas celle
des organisateurs
oui je vous en prie Monsieur Vito juste
des petits points sur le dernier point
que je viens d'abord démarrer
suite à l'intervention auprès du cabinet
de la Première ministre les secours sont
arrivés mais sont arrivés du département
voisin donc moi je vous laisse
interpréter mais en tout cas c'est pas
les ambulances du département des
Deux-Sèvres qui sont arrivés du SMUR des
Deux-Sèvres c'est les ambulances du
souvenir de Charente qui est venu au
secours des blessés graves alors que on
voyait les camions de pompiers ils
étaient à portée de vue ils étaient à
moins d'un kilomètre et c'est les
secours de l'hôpital de Ruffec qui sont
venus porter secours aux blessés les
plus graves dont Michael et ensuite
Esther voilà donc ça c'est premier point
deuxième point je voulais revenir sur
tes questions Florent et sur le sujet de
la violence moi je tout le monde le dit
mais je veux le redire il y avait 30000
personnes et les gens qui étaient là
c'était des familles des familles avec
des poussettes avec des enfants des et
voilà les
fanfare il y avait aucune enfin je veux
dire c'était pas une manifestation de
gens hostile haineux qui était venu là
pour en découde c'était vraiment une une
marche très familiale et donc il y avait
pas cette cette volonté de violence
après effectivement dans le cortège on
les a vu on peut pas le contester des
gens se sont greffés au cortège et qui
effectivement étaient violents mais ça
effectivement comment les juguler et sur
la question très importante de est-ce
que si on avait été organisateur on
aurait annulé
je peux pas me prononcer pour le parti
mais mais je peux me prononcer à titre
individuel moi de comment je j'ai vécu
les choses et moi par rapport à ce que
ce qui s'est passé jusqu'au vendredi
soir vous parlez d'un vendredi qui
commençait à être anxiogène moi je me
rappelle
l'arrivée des tracteurs de la
Confédération paysanne sur le sur la
parcelle et ça c'était pas du tout
anxiogène c'était bien au contraire un
grand moment d'émotion que de voir des
paysans qui s'inquiètent de l'avenir de
leur
et voilà c'était un cortège alors ça
tranche avec les cortège de la FNSE
c'est-à-dire que quand vous êtes avec
des drapeaux de la FNSEA les forces de
l'ordre vous escorte vous avez des des
épandeurs alizés des épandeurs de fumier
dans le dos du tracteur qui vont finir
sur des établissements publics là vous
êtes escorté par les forces de l'ordre
vous arrivez avec des drapeaux de la
Confédération paysanne on vous empêche
de circuler voilà je c'est juste une
petite parenthèse mais y compris ce que
au soir puisque c'était 19h quand la
Confédération paysanne rejoint le ou 20h
même peut-être le terrain de
rassemblement c'est très bon en France
c'est c'est c'est la joie de voir des
paysans qui rejoignent le mouvement et
donc jusqu'à ce moment là il y a aucune
raison d'annuler et combien même
enfin et là c'est très personnel je sais
pas c'est pas concert avec mes collègues
mais
il y a pas de raison le samedi que on
annule justement par rapport à ces
éléments là en revanche moi je suis le
dimanche il y a une conférence de presse
de poste post manifestation le dimanche
matin
et là effectivement je suis le seul élu
à la table de cette conférence de presse
mais les organisateurs sont à la table
de cette conférence de presse c'est une
non merci certains syndicats dont la
Confédération paysanne et là et c'est là
où je suis pas d'accord avec l'analyse
où on flirte avec des appels à la
violence toutes les organisations toutes
les prises de parole à cette conférence
de presse du dimanche matin du 26 mars
dénonce toutes les formes de violence
c'est sans aucune ambiguïté et sur la
question est-ce qu'il fallait annuler la
manifestation la position
globale qui à retenir c'est il ne
fallait probablement pas annuler cette
manifestation nous aurions dû peut-être
modifier la façon dont elle s'est
déroulée c'est ça qui se dit cette
conférence de presse il y a une
captation voilà une captation vidéo elle
est disponible vous pouvez vous pouvez
la consulter c'était le dimanche matin à
mail et tous les organisateurs disent
effectivement donc c'est une forme de de
graines de reconnaissance que on aurait
peut-être pu faire autrement et que on
change dans le parcours on aurait
peut-être pu éviter le désastre parce
que on était quand même traumatisé le
dimanche le matin de ce qui s'est passé
donc voilà ça c'est un avis très
personnel mais mais je vous invite à
regarder quand même cette conférence de
presse du dimanche matin où les
organisateurs s'expriment et tous
dénoncent les violences tous et tous
disent on aurait peut-être dû faire
autrement et c'est là où ils prennent
l'engagement devant la presse de dire si
on doit à nouveau se rassembler sur le
sujet des méga bassines on changera de
mode opératoire c'est le mot qui a
utilisé on changera de mode opératoire
on ne peut plus accepter que des
violences comme celles à laquelle auquel
on a assisté se reproduise et ils ont
tenu promesse regardez ce qui s'est
passé à la fin du mois d'août le convoi
de l'eau c'est pas du tout le même mode
opératoire c'est pas un mode opératoire
ou des militants des des
écologistes vont à la confrontation avec
les forces de l'ordre c'est bon esprit
et ça c'est très très bien passé donc
voilà ce que je pouvais te donner en
réponse en réaction alors c'est pas
complètement la réponse que que tu
espérait peut-être mais mais c'est ce
que moi j'ai vécu on est là pour
témoigner ce que moi j'ai vécu Amel et
dernière chose Amel
la journée d'avant et la journée d'après
sainte Soline c'est-à-dire celle du 24
mars où on a eu plein de conférences
autour de l'eau celle du dimanche où il
y a eu également plein une conférence
autour de l'eau c'est parfaitement bien
déroulé pas de heure avec les forces de
l'ordre et et une construction de de ces
deux journées avant et après avec les
services officiels de l'État qui se sont
bien déroulés donc c'est la preuve que
on a des organisateurs qui sont quand
même en capacité aussi d'organiser des
événements de bonne qualité
trois tout petites choses la première
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de ces assauts
qui sont menacées les organisateurs sur
la subvention qui perdent leur
subventions du fait du contrat
d'engagement et publicain et je vous
rappelle qu'alternatiba à Poitiers
quelques temps auparavant
perf enfin en fait la mairie de Poitiers
est sanctionnée dans sa dans sa
subvention alternative parce qu'ils ont
organisé un village de deux jours dans
lequel il y avait un débat non pas pour
dire on va vous expliquer comment on
désobéit c'est un débat sur ce qu'il
faut faire de la désobéissance civile
c'était ça le tel des bagues des pour
des contre on y est pour juste
l'organisation de un débat en deux jours
il perdent la préfète sanctionne leur
subventions et c'est ça l'ambiance en
Charente donc c'est normal que voilà ils
sont un peu mieux la deuxième chose
c'est que c'est quand même la
responsabilité de l'État ah oui allez-y
et alors d'autant plus pardon que moi
j'ai un TGV à 18h11
c'est public désolé
de déplacement
j'en ai perdu le fil
oui là
l'État ne sanctionne pas
l'activité d'une structure associative
l'état non le contrat d'engagement
républicain j'étais rapporté en général
du texte nous l'avons fait adopter parce
que l'État n'a pas à financer
est-ce non mais l'état la structure
publique les puissances publiques quelle
qu'elle soit n'ont pas à financer nous
semble-t-il des opérations qui visent à
valoriser la déodoration civile personne
n'interdit à l'association de dire la
désobéissance civile c'est bien
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure nous avons vu
des des commentaires qui expliquent
pourquoi les yeux nécessaires par contre
nous considérons que la puissance
publique sous toutes ses formes la base
a appuyé financièrement des opérations
fustèle ponctuelles qui visent à plaider
pour la désobéissance civique donc
celles et ceux qui nous regardent ne
pensent pas que on vise à interdire
celles et ceux qui voudraient développer
des stratégies d'obéissance civile ça
n'est pas le cas la structure
associative elle existe elle n'est pas
interdite elle n'est pas dissoute elle
ne sera jamais sauf si évidemment elle
pose des troubles tout à fait
particulièrement public et qu'en
revanche il revient pas à l'argent des
contribuables d'aller financer des
opérations de ce type c'est tout
je suis désolé mais c'est pas le constat
que nous on fait après la manifestation
d'octobre 2022 l'association de
protection d'information et d'études de
l'eau et de l'environnement l'apiee
s'est fait retirer une subvention à
destinée à financer les animations
nature parce qu'elle avait coordonné
cette manifestation le festival
alternativa c'était deux jours deux
jours de festival avec ce débat au
milieu la ville de Poitiers
subventionnée se comme je peux vous dire
la ville de donne un exemple de
rouennais là où ça s'est très bien passé
sur cette contournement est le maire de
Val-de-Reuil qui est le numéro 3 de LVMH
à prêter toutes les tentes pour les
chaises les tables pour
l'organisation de ce rassemblement comme
le font plein de vie pour plein de
rassemblements avec lesquels ils sont
pas forcément invités et tout ça
dans plein de villes enfin ça se passe
tout le temps comme ça ça veut pas dire
vous êtes d'accord avec tout c'était un
débat d’atterie pas sur deux jours et la
ville de Poitiers qui avait subventionné
ce festival comme ils font pour plein a
été interdite par la préfet et ils sont
il y a un contentieux et en ce moment
là-dessus moi je peux vous dire la messe
à Lille la maison de la c'est ça fait 40
ans que ça existe je peux vous dire si
vous avez une image de qui pourrait être
éco terroriste dans votre tête c'est pas
eux voilà et ben c'est Jean ont été
parce qu'ils organisaient vous savez
chez nous il y a l'aéroport de Lesquin
avec une extension de la piste donc on
est en 2023 normalement les gens à part
le président de la République ont
compris qu'il y avait un problème il
fallait prendre un peu moins l'avion et
donc on est en plus les pistes il y a
les manifs et dans plein de pays
d'Europe il y a le même problème comme
l'île c'est un peu central en Europe il
y a un rassemblement de tous ces gens
d'Europe qui viennent à La Bresse qui
prêtent la salle et ils font des
réunions je pense qu'ils font ils se
coordonnent voilà il y a BFM Lille qui
va désolé c'est encore ils vont parce
qu'ils sont priorité direct donc ils
sont sur tous les champs d'action ils
sont devant et les journalistes disent
bon bah voilà il y a une réunion en ce
moment dans ses locaux apparemment ils
font une formation là désobéissance
civile c'était même pas vrai il dit
apparemment il ferait une et et sur
cette base là mon Président de Région
Xavier Bertrand écrit au Préfet en
disant suspicion alerte CER je demande à
ce qu'on coupe les subventions à
l'adresse qui avait juste prêté la salle
qui était même pas la Réunion
parce que quelqu'un avait dit à la télé
apparemment ils font une formation vous
voyez jusqu'où ça va donc c'est une
répression disproportionnée mais moi en
plus je veux pas que la loi s'applique
pas quand on désobéit en plus on sait ce
qui nous attend certains d'entre nous
ici qui ont fauché les OGM etc on sait à
quoi s'attendre et on l'assume ce que je
dis juste c'est que le droit n'est pas
appliqué partout pareil pour les mêmes
personnes et ça c'est embêtant et juste
sur la liberté de manifester vous disiez
tout à l'heure quand même etc c'est la
responsabilité de l'État de garantir la
liberté de manifester et donc à un
moment on peut pas interdire toutes les
manifestations et d'ailleurs ce que
montre sainte Soline c'est tragique mais
c'est quand même la discussion enfin ce
qu'on doit attirer aussi comme
conclusion c'est que interdire des
manifestations ne crée pas de la
sécurité ni pour les manifestants ni
pour les forces de l'ordre c'est un
échec sur tous les plans ça a mis en
danger les manifestants qui ont
manifestaient quand même et les forces
de l'ordre et peut-être que si une fois
tous les 10 ans on interdisait une
manifestation parce que vraiment c'est
très grave tout le monde dirait ah là
c'est très grave j'y vais pas mais quand
c'est devenu monnaie courante de de
d'interdire des manifestations quand
c'est devenu monnaie courante de
dissoudre il y a eu c'était avant le
mandat d'Emmanuel Macron une virgule 5
dissolution en moyenne par an depuis son
mandat on arrivait à 5,5 par an quand on
dit on va dissouter l'association il y a
pas un émois dans la France en disant il
se passe vraiment un truc très grave on
dit oh ben tu as une de plus parce
qu'ils ont dû faire ils doivent pas être
très net c'est on s'est accoutumé à ça
et c'est un vrai risque pour nos
libertés publiques elles sont en train
de reculer et évidemment que si une
association est en dehors des clous
c'est très dangereux enfin il y a des
motifs pour lesquels on peut contrevenir
à cette liberté d'association mais ce
que montre l'arrêt du Conseil d'État
est-ce que confirmera sûrement quand ce
sera joué au fond c'est que il y avait
pas les éléments nécessaires on n'était
pas dans le respect de l'État de droit
il y avait il y avait pas de raison de
dissoudre cette association la
sanctionner peut-être les surveiller il
va de toute façon c'est fait et de
manière très très lourde depuis des mois
les dissoudre non voilà
peut-être que puisqu'il y a des
collègues qui ont pas encore parlé je
voudrais pas arriver de leur liberté
s'y exprimer et puis ensuite on va quand
même passer aussi la parole aux
collègues qui souhaitent encore
interagir avec vous donc monsieur Oudoul
c'est magnifique donc monsieur salmon je
vous en prie merci monsieur le Président
de donner la parole vous vous posiez la
question de de la genèse de tout cela
parce que effectivement les commissions
d'enquête a quand même pour but de de
comprendre et des éviter que les choses
se reproduisent de la mer de paille
manières
je vais vous donner simplement un
exemple qui peut amener à cette
conflictualité extrême j'ai eu un sms
hier du maire de Corcoué-sur-Logne
Corcoué-sur-Logne au sud de la
Loire-Atlantique on doit y implanter il
y a un projet pour réimplanter un
méthaniseur XXL
qui est complètement décrié j'ai été
rapporté une mission d'information sur
la méthanisation on a mis pointé ce
projet pour montrer que c'était ce qu'il
ne fallait pas faire en méthanisation
il y a eu un certain nombre de riverains
d'associations d'élus qui se sont
mobilisés très nombreux sur ce contre ce
projet
il y a eu vraiment
un travail d'effectuer au niveau du
conseil départemental de
Loire-Atlantique sur ce sujet au bout du
compte qu'est-ce que l'on constate
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a eu une
enquête publique et qu'il y a eu un avis
favorable qui a été donné sur ce projet
de Corcoué sur Lognes très clairement
ici on est dans un déni de démocratie et
les collectifs les associations qui ont
fait qui ont fait confiance aux élus
pour porter leur voix contre ce projet
qui n'a aucun sens ce centre
complètement trahi et qu'est-ce qu'il va
se passer derrière et bien on ne sait
pas mais certainement d'autres
mobilisations ça ne va pas en rester là
donc demain et bien il y aura sans doute
des manifestations sur corpus sur le
on n'est pas très loin de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes on est dans le
même département et bien j'espère que
l'État va enfin et le gouvernement va
enfin prendre conscience qu'on ne peut
pas appliquer toujours ses stratégies
qui se terminent toujours dans une eau
violence voilà ça c'est un élément de
Genèse sinon collègue
parlait tout à l'heure de la stratégie
des associations des organisateurs sur
Sainte Soline qui évolue mais je pense
que la stratégie aussi des forces de
l'ordre doit bien entendu évoluer moi
juste deux mots pour vous dire ce que
j'ai constaté j'ai constaté sur sur site
qu'on était dans une stratégie du fortin
aciergé très clairement
toutes les éléments étaient là pour
qu'il y ait conflictualité effectivement
on avait en face un certain nombre de
jambes de personnes qui voulaient aller
qui voulait monter sur les sur les
digues pour planter des drapeaux on peut
trouver ça péril enfin c'était un
c'était ainsi il voulait monter et en
face et bien on avait comme dans les
bons vieux Far West des vieux films du
Far West
toutes les forces de l'ordre autour on
aurait dit des chariots qui étaient
autour de la bassine et puis les Indiens
qui attaquaient en gros on était là on
était là pour faire je pense des belles
images parce que ces véhicules qui
étaient autour je me demande quel était
leur vocation si ce n'est à faire des
belles images il est évident que
de la fumée aurait pu sortir rapidement
de ces véhicules c'est ce qui est arrivé
donc je pense qu'il a on a eu une
stratégie qui était une stratégie
clairement de l'affrontement donc il
faut absolument que les forces de
l'ordre tirent des conclusions de ce qui
s'est passé là parce que ça ne peut pas
se reproduire moi j'en suis sorti
profondément touché amer parce que
n'allions pas sur cet endroit on y
allait pour finir dans ces conditions de
violence de blesser
certains dans un état très grave on y
allait pour faire des manifestations
comme le font souvent les écologistes
j'ai participé à de nombreux
manifestations qui partent plutôt dans
un esprit festif pour porter nos valeurs
et donc je pense que des stratégies
doivent évoluer à ce niveau là parce que
nous sommes dans un moment d'extrême
tension dans la société de plus en plus
palpable
ou vous le savez très bien sur les 9
limites planétaires 6 ont été dépassés
la dernière concerne le cycle de l'eau
le cycle de l'eau douce et donc demain
et bien effectivement on peut s'attendre
à ce que de nombreuses personnes avoir
20 ans en 2023 ce n'est pas simple face
à tous les défis qui sont devant nous et
que de nombreuses personnes si personne
ne répond à leur demande à leurs
aspirations pour une habitabilité de la
terre nombreuses personnes prennent
différentes voix qui seront pas
forcément les voix de la démocratie
représentative
monsieur Odoul pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
secrétaire nationale messieurs les
parlementaires
à vous entendre vous détenez la vérité
universelle vous êtes les grands
défenseurs de l'intérêt général et donc
sa justifie tout sa justifie les actions
illégales ça justifie la désobéissance
civile et vous vous étonnez même ton
délié de l'image déplorable qu'on les
écologistes aujourd'hui mais cette image
elle est nourrie elle est alimentée
aussi par les comportements de vos amis
quand vous avez certains de vos amis qui
bloquent le périphérique et qui
excusez-moi l'expression qui emmerde les
usagers et ceux qui vont aller
travailler quand vous avez certains de
vos amis qui dégradent asperges des
toiles des tableaux dans les musées
quand vous avez certains de vos amis qui
saccagent des dizaines de cultures au
mépris du travail des agriculteurs
monsieur Biteau quand vous avez aussi
votre partie
qui accueille en grande pompe le rappeur
antisémite et homophobe Médine voilà
comment vous pouvez un moment donné sans
remettre en cause sans vous remettre en
cause justement
nier ou en tout cas vous étonnez de
l'image déplorable car votre mouvement
et l'écologie politique aujourd'hui
alors Monsieur Biteau vous disiez aussi
comment on fait aujourd'hui quand on est
attaché à l'état de droit quand on a
envie de changer les choses quand on est
républicains etc et je vous espérez que
nous sommes républicains et attachés à
la tête droite tous les deux il y a
quelque chose qui s'appelle en
démocratie l'élection la participation
la confrontation d'idées monsieur le
sénateur dans ma circonscription j'ai
aussi un méthaniseur industriel avec une
formidable association à Fougères qui
s'oppose à l'installation de ce
méthaniseur et qui le fait pacifiquement
avec tous les moyens légaux et que je
soutiens également avec tous les moyens
légaux il y a pas de violence il y a pas
désobéissance civile et ça se fait très
bien donc moi je considère que vous nous
dites que vous êtes un mouvement
pacifique
c'est pas réellement vrai très
clairement vous soutenez des actions
violentes vous cautionnez des actions
violentes vous parlez de violence
policières ce qui alimentent justement
la haine de nos forces de l'ordre et
j'aimerais vous interroger précisément
sur une phrase de l'une de vos députés
d'une députés écologistes qu'elle a
prononcé qu'elle a déclaré le 6 juin
dernier madame Sandrine Rousseau qui
nous dit la seule issue à une colère
populaire devient la violence est-ce que
c'est pas de l'incitation la violence et
vous qui vous dites Pacifique qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de cette phrase je vous
remercie
avec vous
c'est bien vous êtes aussi sympa en vrai
que sur les réseaux sociaux et en fait
depuis deux heures quasiment on débat
sereinement c'est ça élève le niveau les
enfin moi je trouve ça intéressant
vraiment et je vous remercie de
l'attitude que vous avez monsieur le
Président Monsieur apoteur qui cherchait
à décrire la vérité sans comme je vous
avais dit en intro dans un objectif
partisan on sera pas d'accord surtout on
en discute on va rechercher la vérité
ensemble et chercher des compromis je
pense que vous projetez sur les autres
vos propres turpitudes monsieur audoul
en plus vous faites un avalgame on vous
explique à l'Europe Écologie Les Verts
il y a les soulèvements de la terre on
vous on vous explique qu'on a des liens
qu'on est pas la même chose vous
mélangez tout mais je sais je peux pas
faire insultes à votre intelligence donc
je sais en plus que vous le faites
exprès donc je vous répondrai pas par
contre il y a un truc que vous avez dit
sur lequel je vais rebondir vous avez
dit il suffit d'être élu et après on
sert des institutions c'est pas aussi
simple que ça
sinon ça se saurait et en profiter
puisque j'avais oublié cet élément sur
mon ami le ministre de l'Intérieur il a
dit une fois et personne ne l'a relevé
dans une matinale peu après sainte
Soline que vraiment il allait empêcher
toutes les AD en France faire un grand
plan il était sur cette stratégie là bon
ok et il dit cette phrase dans la
matinale il y en a même certains d'entre
eux qui font de l'emprise dans les
conseils municipaux
bah en fait de l'entrisme dans un parti
je vois ce que c'est l'entrée dans une
asso je vois ce que c'est de l'entrée
dans un conseil municipal ça s'appelle
une élection et normalement le ministre
de l'Intérieur devrait le savoir merci
de m'avoir permis cette précision
oui je vous en prie
juste répondre très rapidement moi je
veux bien que vous nous interpelliez en
tant qu' élu et
et mais justement parce que on est du et
que on a utilisé tout ce que la
République nous offre les recours en
justice la consultation de la communauté
scientifique la consultation des
citoyens parce que ils enquêtes
publiques et toutes les enquêtes
publiques ont amené à un avis négatif
sur les bassines quand il faut que vous
sachiez
je repose ma question très simplement à
fortiori quand on est élu et qu'on est
attaché à l'état de droit quand la
justice nous donne raison quand la
communauté scientifique nous donne
raison quand les enquêtes publiques nous
donnerons et que c'est des décisions
préfectorales qui engagent les travaux
comme ça c'est fait à Sylvain comme ça
c'est fait à la ligne tranche avant les
5 bassines qui sont interdites et qu'on
mobilise autant d'argent public parce
que c'est l'angle mort de notre
réflexion autant d'argent public sur ces
équipements là comment est-ce que quand
on est élu attaché à l'état de droit
attaché aux décisions de justice
attachée
aux expertises scientifiques on fait
comment comment fait-on à part
manifester à côté des citoyens pour
réclamer le respect de l'État de droit
moi c'est ça la question que je pose et
je pense que les élus doivent être
justement en tête de ces cortèges-là et
je me pose même une question c'est
est-ce que c'est les élus qui n'étaient
pas à côté de ces 30000 citoyens à
sainte-solin qui sont pas dans l'erreur
moi c'est la question que je vous pose
en regardant on se retournant pour le
coup puisque tout à l'heure tu regardais
devant avec les mais en regardant un
petit peu l'histoire des droits humains
moi je pense que l'abolition de
l'esclavage aux États-Unis a commencé
par des manifestations interdites
moi je pense que la lutte contre
l'abolition de l'apartheid en Afrique du
Sud a commencé par des bénéfices
le droit l'avortement en France dans les
années 60 a commencé par des
manifestations interdites et qui
aujourd'hui irait contesté ces
mouvements populaires citoyens qui
veulent faire avancer le droit d'avoir
agi et d'avoir
pousser les choses moi je pense que dans
cette alors là les méga bassines elles
ouvrent quoi de nouveau dans le paysage
une agriculture industrielle extrêmement
prédatrice sur nos biens communs et là
c'est l'eau en ouvrant une nouvelle
brèche qui est celle de la dérégulation
du cycle de l'eau ce qui est
catastrophique on va tous empire à un
moment donné et que des gens s'élèvent
contre ça pour moi mais le débat de des
méga bassines sur un débat citoyen
absolument énorme dans la société
d'aujourd'hui ça doit être mis à ce
niveau là et que il est des
manifestations contre ça je vois pas
comment ça ne peut pas être et je vois
pas comment nous les élus qui portons
une autre idée de l'agriculture et un
autre modèle d'agriculture ne soyons pas
à notre place dans ces manifestations et
pour moi l'erreur c'est de l'avoir
interdite la manifestation n'aurait pas
été interdite
là il y aurait pas eu la rupture avec
les organisateurs avec toutes les
conséquences que ça a eu comme ça
fonctionné le gros problème qui qui se
pose là c'est cette création de rupture
volontaire moi je pense volontaire pour
scénariser tout ce qu'on a pu connaître
après qui a été recherché mais pas par
les manifestants pas par les
manifestants voilà d'ailleurs pour
préciser et répondre à ce que vous avez
dit
en tout cas simplement un point
ayant été hier sur place quand vous
dites il y avait une recherche
volontaire de rupture je ne sais pas je
m'interroge je mets en tout état de
cause de la part des représentants aussi
bien de l'État que des forces de l'ordre
c'est pas ce que j'ai entendu et donc
donc voilà en tout cas il y avait une à
plusieurs reprises il y a quand même un
certain nombre de faisceaux qui laissent
à penser qui qui a eu un certain nombre
d'actions qui avaient été engagés pour
essayer de créer le lien après je vous
laisse évidemment juge de
l'interprétation qui qui fait que le
lien est enfin je pense que
factuellement on est d'accord sur un
point c'est que le lien ne s'est pas
établi donc après
qui est à l'origine de du fait que il ne
se soit pas établi voilà après on va
rechercher des causalités
mais mais une chose est sûre c'est que
le fait que le lien n'est pas eu lieu et
source de problème et d'ailleurs ça
montre en tout état de cause que dans un
état de droit il est important qui est
du dialogue et que dès lors que il n'y a
pas de dialogue et bien on risque de
d'aller sur des formes d'affrontement où
tout le monde est perdant et surtout
quand ça dérive vers vers des formes
violentes dont de toute évidence
personne n'a voulu sauf peut-être celles
et ceux qui étaient venus avec cette
intentionnalité violente
juste une réponse hasard moi pour
préciser ma pensée je pense pas que je
suis allé forces de l'ordre donc j'ai
cherché un scénarisé ça se passe bien au
dessus de le sujet de la rupture je
parle qu'ils ont créé c'est pas nous
ça se passe au-dessus
monsieur Corman je vous en prie oui
d'abord monsieur le Président à monsieur
le rapporteur qui peut-être nous regarde
dans le train et merci à lui tout à
l'heure je voulais vous hésiter très
sincèrement sur la manière dont vous
menez ces discussions je vous remercie
notamment dans votre propos liminaire
d'avoir
équilibré en quelque sorte les
formulations initiales de cette
commission d'enquête en c'est comme ça
que je l'ai perçu on élargissant un peu
le focus pour avoir une vision
d'ensemble sur ce qui s'est passé à
Sainte-Souline mais vous l'avez compris
dans nos propos ça ne Soline et d'un
symptôme d'un mal plus large qui frappe
nos pays et là c'est aussi avec la
casquette de députés européens pas
seulement en France ou on constate à
l'échelle de nos démocraties européennes
mais ça va aussi au-delà un raidissement
considérable
de l'expression de la capacité
d'expression démocratique
donc à la lumière de ce constat
j'aimerais attirer l'attention parce
qu'on a été interrogé à ce propos sur la
question le concept de désobéissance
civile
c'est un concept qui est compliqué parce
que à la fois par définition la
désobéissance civile c'est une
proposition d'action militante qui sort
du cadre de la loi ce qui légale
personne peut le contester est néanmoins
et je pense qu'en tant que y compris
législateur et élu on doit entendre que
pour autant c'est un mode de militance
qui ne sort pas de ce qu'on appelle
l'arc républicain dans la mesure et
c'est son périmètre de définition il
repousse la violence contre les
personnes
et en tant que écologiste j'attire aussi
votre attention là-dessus à ma
connaissance nous sommes le seul
mouvement d'idée qui existe maintenant
depuis 50 ans qui a toujours exclu y
compris dans ces formes de
radicalisation les plus importantes la
violence contre les personnes on le sait
dans les l'ensemble des mouvements de
droite traditionnels ou de gauche
traditionnelle il y a eu parfois le
recours à des attentats contre des
personnes à des violences contre des
personnes le mouvement écologiste dans
son histoire qui n'est pas que française
n'a jamais eu recours aux violences
contre les personnes et c'est pas parce
qu'on est meilleur que les autres
c'est parce que dans la définition de
notre corpus politique la question de la
non-violence et centrale et pourquoi
parce qu'on considère que par rapport à
leurs idées que nous portons qu'on peut
partager ou pas
l'acceptabilité consentie les gens et
déterminants et donc ça vient pas de
nulle part et donc c'est pour ça
également qu'on a une forme d'expérience
dans nos pratiques de militance de
terrain qui sont dans l'intégration de
désobéir et Claude assez brillamment
enfin factuellement en tout cas rappeler
en quoi dans l'histoire des idées et
dans l'histoire des progrès humains le
fait à un moment d'avoir désobéi à ce
qui était la règle était certes illégale
mais légitime mais nous nous sommes
toujours dans cette pension et notre et
cette réflexion là et donc on peut dire
oui mais attention là vous déborder etc
etc nous sommes prêts à débattre de ça
par contre la limite très claire
constante de la part du mouvement
écologiste c'est le refus des violences
contre les personnes deuxième chose sur
ce qu'on est tourné autour de ça de la
doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
j'ai bien compris que le propos c'était
de comprendre
l'origine de la violence de la part de
certains manifestants je pense vraiment
qu'il faut entendre que la manière dont
on exerce le maintien de l'ordre a une
incidence sur la manière dont s'exprime
les manifestations
c'est d'ailleurs la moindre des choses
quand on réfléchit à une doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre par définition on
cherche des résultats pour cueillez le
moins de violence possible et là encore
en tant député européen qui regardons ce
qui se passe dans d'autres pays
européens en termes de doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre j'ai le regret de
dire que la France est une exception
dans ces méthodes et que nous ne sommes
pas ceux qui obtenons les meilleurs
résultats tout à l'heure une question
fort légitime était posée sur
je crois que c'était par vous sur quand
les conditions de manifestation sereine
ne sont pas réunies et ce qu'il faut
quand même aller manifester si un vrai
débat mais j'ai envie de vous dire ça
fait quand même maintenant très
longtemps que quasiment systématiquement
les conditions sereine de manifestations
ne sont plus réunis et ça pas toujours
été le cas comment ça se fait qu'est-ce
qui se passe pourquoi c'est ça pourquoi
il se passe ça et ça est vraiment je le
dis un peu avec solennité même si c'est
inutile parce que vous l'avez à l'esprit
en tant que législateur en tant que
député ton peu de mission est aussi de
contrôler l'exécutif c'est vraiment une
question fondamentale à se poser parce
que on peut faire autrement on peut
vraiment faire autrement et dernier
point
par rapport à la crise climatique par
rapport aux tensions que ça entraîne par
rapport aux comment dire au refus au
rejet des modèles
traditionnels de partie de
représentation nous avons quand je dis
nous en tant que représentant politique
en tant que à comprendre que les modes
d'intervention que les modes de
militance
évoluent c'est qu'on a plus même s'ils
sont toujours nécessaires c'est pas moi
qui vais vous le dire contraire puisque
je mets dans un parti politique nous
n'avons plus uniquement ce qu'on appelle
les corps intermédiaires traditionnels
vous avez des mobs de militance
d'intervention d'expressions qui sont
plus liquides plus horizontaux et donc
il y a deux attitudes à avoir pour -2 à
avoir par rapport à ça soit on dit on
veut pas en entendre parler et quelque
part on l'appréhende par une forme de
répression soit on le prend en compte
pour l'intégrer à la qualité du débat
démocratique global et quand il y a une
forme
de répression ou de réaction du pouvoir
impréciser entre eux les personnes qui
viennent pour en découdre et d'autres
j'attire vraiment l'attention sur le
fait que c'est une usine à fabriquer des
personnes qui vont du coup se dire bah
mon seul issue ça va être d'utiliser la
méthode violente et donc la stratégie
qu'on doit avoir en tant que législateur
en tant que représentant en tant que
celles et ceux qui voulons faire vivre
notre démocratie
c'est bien sûr de condamner ça a été
répété par Marine par nous tous les
formes de violence contre les personnes
dans les expressions politiques mais
c'est aussi de s'organiser pour que les
choses ne
s'aggravent pas et dernier mot parce que
je pense que c'est très grave le terme
d'écotérisme
pour tout vous dire je pense que y
compris la façon un peu légère donc ça a
été traitée et liée au fait que ça
visait des écolos en tout cas c'est
comme ça que je le vis peut-être que
c'est tôt c'est très grave vraiment je
vous invite à regarder quels sont les
régimes politiques où les gens au
pouvoir qualifient leurs opposants de
terroristes regardez autour du monde
dans quel type de pays ça se passe comme
ça aucune démocratie aucune démocratie
sans aucun autre pays démocratique
européen ou extra-européen ou un pouvoir
dit mes opposants sont météoristes dans
aucun des cas c'est une démocratie
et le rôle des parlementaires c'est de
contrôler l'action de l'exécutif mais
dans l'action de l'exécutif il y a aussi
les mots qui l'utilisent et on ne peut
pas utiliser certains mots à la légère
non seulement évidemment par rapport à
l'histoire récente de notre pays mais
au-delà de ça c'est quelque chose qui
disqualifie la capacité même à pouvoir
dialoguer alors une démocratie on tue la
capacité de dialoguer
en quelle mesure l'espérance de vie
démocratique d'un tel pays et important
donc partons d'avoir été mais
franchement au-delà vous avez une
occasion en or en réalité à partir de
sainte-solide ce qui s'est passé à
Sainte Soline a pointé les
responsabilités de la web-être mais
aussi d'élargir le regard que ça
implique par rapport au travail immense
que vous que nous mais au niveau
européen
le travail énormément pour
résister à la régression démocratique
que nous sommes en temps de vivre pas
seulement en France et dans d'autres
pays c'est évidemment plus grave parce
qu'il y a une véritable menace et si on
ne fait rien si on n'est pas vigilant
enfin ça va pas s'arranger tout seul
donc merci de nous avoir permis d'avoir
créé le cadre de dialogue qui permet
d'exprimer ces choses-là après bien sûr
chacun y prendra ce qu'il veut ou ce
qu'elle veut mais c'est moi le cœur du
message voilà c'est pas c'est pas de
faire les filles en haut c'est pas de
dire machin on a raison c'est d'exprimer
notre inquiétude par rapport au bassines
par rapport aux ressources naturelles
mais au-delà de ça par rapport à dans un
cadre démocratique et politique
qui nous permet de continuer à pouvoir
dialoguer dans notre société
bien simplement un point pour que
par rapport à ce que ce que vous dites
monsieur gourmand la Commission depuis
le début de ces travaux c'est justement
penché sur les modalités de ce schéma
national du maintien de l'ordre et
d'ailleurs comment dire un certain
nombre d'auditions que vous avez
peut-être eu l'occasion de visionner et
de suivre mettre l'accent là-dessus
c'est vrai que ce qui nous ce qui nous
motive et quand vous regardez un certain
nombre de points sur lesquels nous
essayons de mettre la focale c'est de se
dire comment est-ce qu'on peut contenir
des personnes qui arrivent sur des
manifestations avec finalement excenté
une intentionnalité de développement de
violence et c'est vrai que ça interroge
pleinement puisque à travers ce mode
opératoire
ils peuvent contribuer à délégitimer la
cause pour la la manifestation
est amené à se déployer et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle je
pense que Madame Tondelier nous avait
sollicité en disant on veut aussi
pouvoir échanger avec la commission
d'enquête parce que évidemment la cause
environnementale pour un certain et ce
que ce qu'on a pu voir c'est que pour
certains en fait la cause
environnementale est détournée de de son
objet et donc ça aussi pardon ah bah
évidemment je je ne vous le fais pas
dire c'est vrai et là il y a une
évidemment une une vraie une vraie
difficulté je vous propose je vois que
leur fil je vous propose de de
terminer cette cet échange en tout cas
merci beaucoup à vous-même madame
Tondelier ainsi qu'à l'ensemble des
membres de la délégation pour pour
l'échange qu'on a pu avoir et donc je
vais
suspendre les travaux pour aujourd'hui
je rappelle au collègue membre de la
commission que nous reprenons nos
auditions dans dans trois semaines avec
l'audition de de Bernard Cazeneuve et
puis
c'est assez inhabituel mais non non mais
non non mais comment dire je ne suis pas
là pour frustrer qui que ce soit donc je
vous en prie c'est vrai que c'est on a
été très long on n'a pas fait 12 heures
comme à Saint-Denis avec le chef d'État
mais on aurait pu et je note qu'il reste
plus que les écologistes d'ailleurs dans
la salle preuve que nous sommes non
violents mais qu'on ne lâche jamais rien
c'est ça
mais bravo à vous monsieur le Président
pour votre président
madame la secrétaire nationale mais je
je suis républicain
je parlais en dehors du président
juste pour terminer sur sur l'objet de
votre commission d'enquête je voulais
juste dire en conclusion que
heureusement par rapport à tout ce qu'on
vient de se dire on peut faire autrement
et que même on doit faire autrement et
que nous cinq on en est convaincu nous
et l'ensemble de notre famille politique
et donc on va faire autrement on est des
experts de violence il y a une valeur
qui nous est chère aussi c'est la
désescalade et l'apaisement quand
j'étais allé voir la première ministre
quelques jours après Sainte-Soline
c'était apaisé le titre de notre
communiqué de presse de nos propositions
on avait d'ailleurs proposé un moratoire
sur les bassines je constate qu'entre
temps la semaine dernière une nouvelle
bassine est entrée en construction
preuve que c'est pas ça que j'appelle de
l'apaisement c'est même plutôt l'inverse
et donc je voulais finir juste par pour
plaider cette désescalade et vous dire
que on sera toujours du côté de celles
et ceux qui la recherche chez Europe
Écologie Les Verts et que même on y
contribuera si on nous y invite enfin on
mettra tout en oeuvre pour y contribuer
avec toutes celles et ceux qui nous
demanderont de de le faire avec eux et
si nous le demande pas on le fera tout
seul voilà
je vous remercie en tout cas vous aurez
noté que ce qui peut en tout cas
rejoindre un certain nombre d'élus c'est
le souhait de faire en sorte un qui est
de la désescalade et que la violence ne
soit pas le le mode d'action pour pour
revendiquer dans dans nos pays
démocratiques merci à vous